[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, previously then, having witnessed the assassination of Theo, the five of you banded together to see if you could investigate the
[SPEAKER_02]: potential assassination or killing of a friend or colleague of the group of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And coming together, you found that there seemed to be at least a guild of engineers turned up very quickly and caused problems for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you found, whilst investigating Theo's background, that there also appeared to be members of the Porter's Guild kind of chasing him down as well, who also caused you further problems.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so it seems like the five of you are on a hit list of some kind, maybe some of you more than others.
[SPEAKER_02]: But certainly people are coming to investigate Theo's associates and you guys have found yourself embroiled in that investigation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Last time, following the aftermath of fighting a pack of howls in the bellows, which ended up with a very close call, you rescued a ledger from Harriet Spurnhold, one of Theo's colleagues at the Guild of Engineers, and inside that ledger was a bunch of scratched out entries.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, the last two
[SPEAKER_02]: still remained legible to you guys, written in both Technic and Parvozzi, and these pointed you guys to Claringburn's Yard, which is the place which Billy works, a scrapper's yard, and also Fexfield Scrappers, a secondary, larger operation, a little bit more professional, that you guys have yet to investigate.
[SPEAKER_02]: You found out from Harriet that this ledger, or at least she kind of hinted towards the idea that Theo was
[SPEAKER_02]: working with some of the people in this ledger to do something to do with the guild and requisitioning objects or items is how she phrased it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You kind of put two and two together at Clarenode's yard when you found that Shrapnel, the owner of the yard and Billy's mentor and boss, had disappeared and the whole place had been smashed to pieces.
[SPEAKER_02]: You found that Felix could surprisingly speak to constructs.
[SPEAKER_02]: of events that nobody has yet to question him on.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I should add here that that for all of you is completely unknown and not a skill that anybody has ever.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like a well-known normal skill that is done.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't think I made that clear at the time because there was a lot going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, you know, speaking with animals, which is essentially what the spell is, is not something that is commonplace in Parvo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, so Felix managed to speak with these constructs, damaged as they were from the attack on
[SPEAKER_02]: Claringburns, and you got some more information that it was in fact the two thugs, let's call them, from the Porter's Guild that you had already tangled with in Oblong Square, who had apparently come smashed up the place and taken Shrapnel away with them.
[SPEAKER_02]: The staff nowhere to be seen, and leaving Billy with an empty yard and a lot of questions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, Lark had
[SPEAKER_02]: attempted to find a place to sleep, ended up at the bathhouse, the Salador's Slip, where a friend of hers lived and she had bunked down for the night with a friend of hers.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, she ran afoul of the matron of the bathhouse by doing so and was summoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: Madame Rook, who owns the top floor of the Salador's Slip, well, owns the whole place, but lives on the top floor, told her that she would need to
[SPEAKER_02]: do a job for her to pay off the debt of sleeping under her roof.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the job was to go and investigate a certain fallen nobleman's son, who was apparently seen around the Plum and Bob and ask of the land and report back to her with that information.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Lark has been given this task and was told to do so by the end of the day, which will be the end of tomorrow as we just ending Wex Day today.
[SPEAKER_02]: All those things aside, you also had a decent, let's say, brainstorm about potential ways in which you could continue.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it definitely seemed like the Porters Guild was the most heavily involved currently.
[SPEAKER_02]: You found that there was a number of, or there was a number next to these ledgers entries that suggested that there was a certain number of something which you guys surmised to be Essence Cores that were
[SPEAKER_02]: to be dealt with by Theo in this in this ledger and what that actually meant you didn't you weren't able to come up with.
[SPEAKER_02]: And finally, everybody got all the information that Asuka's father is Valerian Velan.
[SPEAKER_02]: who is working with Professor Buckman on projects that nobody would discuss.
[SPEAKER_02]: And many of you actually have connections and whatever to him in various ways, but we didn't explore that quite to the end of the trail there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So finally then,
[SPEAKER_02]: At the end of the day, everyone except Lark has had a long rest because basically Calder has gone back to his dorm to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aska has gone back, performed at the Plum and Bob and slept.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix took a tavern close to Fexfield Scrappers and Billy went home to sleep at his home with the intention that, I think if I'm right, it's Billy and Felix are gonna head to Fexfield Scrappers the next morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: That was first going to go to the bone yard again or the scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're going to go to the scrapyard and then go and meet Felix at Fixfield scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, one thing I'm going to add is a little mechanic for you, Asko, which is I would like you to make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_01]: A stealth check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's starting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I quickly ask about Valoran?
[SPEAKER_03]: Did we hear that
[SPEAKER_03]: he is still working with the professor or was working with the professor?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god, my first natural one.
[SPEAKER_01]: My first natural one.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's perfect for this.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good start of the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think various people heard different things about Valoran and I don't think it was more that he was, the important part wasn't that he was working now with Professor Buckman, but it's that people knew who he was because of his connection to Professor Buckman.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like,
[SPEAKER_02]: potentially Billy and Calder because of their connection to Professor Buckman knew about Asuka's father or knew of him or knew some connection to him in some way that's just a it was a relatively minor connection but it's more that it's more that Asuka sort of it's finally confirmed that he's a member of the Volan family and stuff which he kind of said but we now kind of confirm and know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a natural one though.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is going to be a mechanic for you performing at the taverns on the evenings, given that you are a wanted man.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a failed stealth check, you will roll a d4 and there is like a hidden number, which when you reach, bad things will happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not gonna tell you what the number is, but you can go and roll a d4 with a failed stealth check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I should make you roll too, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, it's not so bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's sort of like a suspicion meter, which, you know, is sort of unknown to Asuka, obviously.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, you know, as you continue to make your face known through performing, and now that there are these rumors out about you, there might be people who are on the lookout for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Lark, you head back to Salador's Slip for the evening, intending to, I think, confront Madame Rook here about...
[SPEAKER_02]: uh what you know or what you don't know or whatever yeah i hope i just get led in by the doorman and if i could just go to madam yeah yeah yeah i think he is expecting you so so to speak at least he knows now that you are sort of oh i'm so nervous already yeah let me find her picture just so that we have it so you head upstairs and you knock on the door
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, why does this not work?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you guys see that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Heading in, you see Madame Rook is sat there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Looks like she's actually about to go to bed because you know that she kind of sleeps relatively early because she gets up very early, which is how you were able to sort of sneak in before.
[SPEAKER_02]: But she's kind of like just tidying up stuff on her desk and like kind of is about to stand up almost as you enter.
[SPEAKER_02]: She calls you in and looks you over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, Madame Rook, to disturb you so late.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just thought I would already come back regarding the information which you requested.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it okay if I come in?
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm pleased to see that you're so eager to help me in this matter.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well...
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, well, regarding that... She's really nervous, just starts to fiddle her fingers around and...
[SPEAKER_03]: well I to be honest I was ready to come here with a lie but that would be stupid of me and I realized that because you of anyone would probably realize a lie and recognize a liar so I am going to be honest with you here that
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, first and foremost, I'm not willing to be any type of... Guys...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not willing to be any type of a pawn if it comes to giving information to certain guilds or certain parts of certain guilds that would help them continue operating in certain ways they do currently.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that being said, my life has already been compromised by the Porteous Guild.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, this information which you requested, if it means that I'm gonna help these certain guild enforcers in any way, I don't need to stay here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just wanted to let you know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: My dear, we haven't even agreed whether you'll be staying here.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is to pay a debt of you already staying in my establishment.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as for the guilds, I assure you this is purely a family matter between family members and whether they're associated with guilds or not is not your concern, I believe.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am just in a weird position currently and
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I'm sort of in a closer position to find out dirt about this certain event that happened during King's Day.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I just, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know your stance with the guilds, madam, or what this family matter could be, but I just feel like I don't want to take any risks disturbing that.
[SPEAKER_03]: investigation that I'm trying to be part of.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just trying to be honest with you.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can do anything you wish with this information, but... Well, you're trying to make a deal, am I right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You are trying to refuse my offer in exchange for something more valuable to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just trying to walk out of the request you gave me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And give me nothing in return?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, what could I help you with?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because, well, I could be useful in some ways.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like this dirt I mentioned.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm in a position where, you know, people don't really suspect me.
[SPEAKER_03]: to be in this position.
[SPEAKER_03]: I could be a helpful extra ear or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is exactly what I'm already asking you to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is what I identified in you in the first place.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the reason that I send you to the pun on Bob is because agents of mine arriving there would be easily noticed and obvious to the members of the local guilds.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whereas you work outside of there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Attention and therefore can get me this information without causing a problem now if you want to make a deal We can make a deal, but I need something of value in return I cannot make a deal on promises or potentials or some other you could disappear in the night And then I'll see nothing of my investment And as I mentioned before I believe your friend Nell would not wish for you to suddenly disappear
[SPEAKER_03]: You probably realize how I'm circling around this topic, that I know something.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, since I'm a really bad liar, so... A person named Eska was performing in the bar, but that's a public name he gave out, but about the surname is not something I would know of.
[SPEAKER_03]: But, you know, putting two and two together,
[SPEAKER_03]: How many people named Escar performing in a bar?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, this is exactly what I need you to find out.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need you to talk to this person, find out if they are Escavalan or just simply another bard who happens to have a poorly chosen first name, and then report back to me so that I can put this information into the right hands for a fee.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is what we do here.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's no use to me to tell them that something they already know, a bard called Esca, is playing.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need confirmation of this information.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to use my luck point.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh my god, Jesus Christ!
[SPEAKER_01]: You are rolling so badly in this game, holy shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just not meant to succeed in here.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not persuasive, she's incredibly nervous, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, Look,
[SPEAKER_02]: You understand, I think, the transactional nature of this arrangement.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need value from you to pay, and I don't need money, and I can see that you don't have money, so I need some other payment for this debt that you have incurred.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe that that is more than fair, given everything else, and if for some reason you have some moral
[SPEAKER_02]: quandary with following up on this ask of a land, then I suggest you find some other piece of information that you have no moral stipulations about giving me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whether that's about a different guild or about a different person, but it has to be of value to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: But know this, if you don't do this task, I will have people that will do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So should you refuse, it's only going to delay the inevitable anyway and cause more problems for yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is the inevitable that you're talking about?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I don't want to cause trouble to anyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the inevitable is that if this is Ask a Volan, his family will find out about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is the ultimate goal here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, the people that I work for are not necessarily his family, but they are searching for him.
[SPEAKER_02]: And his family, as I'm sure you're aware, the Volans, are a powerful family within the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they have paid me, they will have paid others, they will be searching for him, and if you know some information that you're withholding now, it becomes valueless the second that somebody else tells me the information.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, it is up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you have something else you wish to trade, some other piece of information, some suggestion, then I am all ears.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if not, I suggest you use the information you have whilst it is valuable, otherwise you will have nothing left to trade.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry Crimson, what other information is she requesting?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I don't really catch it.
[SPEAKER_03]: What other valuable information?
[SPEAKER_03]: Does it need to be regarding this matter?
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly this.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you understand that she is just a trader of information.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you had some kind of information that you think she would be able to sell to someone else, then that would have value to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it depends if you can think of anything, have anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not saying you do or don't have something.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying that's an option she's presenting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, well, I knew there was a person named Asuka performing during King's Day.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you know probably the events of the King's Day as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: And well, what I said about my life being compromised by the Porteous Guild, that's how they got me, because Theodore Blackwood died.
[SPEAKER_03]: And they just wanted information, the Porteous Guild, from anyone who knew Theo.
[SPEAKER_03]: So about Porter's Guild, I just know that they have had problems with Theo and now they're trying to find out anyone who can finish those deals with them.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's some valuable information I have currently.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a start.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know what their deals entail?
[SPEAKER_02]: What they wish to find out?
[SPEAKER_02]: What they did with
[SPEAKER_02]: this Theo or perhaps their connections to anything greater than a debt?
[SPEAKER_03]: Something so big that they're willing to, they're willing to kill people in public for it.
[SPEAKER_02]: She sort of laughs and says, my dear in this business, that's a powerful course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, since you clearly, and let me be clear, I'm not so foolish to think that you don't therefore know this Asuka, else why would you be protecting him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Should you wish to give me some information on someone other than who I assume is Asuka Velan, then I suggest you go and find that information and bring that to me instead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I have no...
[SPEAKER_02]: no skin in the game, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will not sell this information to the bidder if you do not give it to me about your friend Asuka, but I will need something to sell instead.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so if you have some sort of dirt on the Porter's Guild, some underhanded tactics, some criminal venture, something like that, I suggest that you come back to me with that instead.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you wish to stop me from
[SPEAKER_02]: given what I already know to be the case, given your reaction to this task.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm no fool in this.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will return to you tomorrow evening.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good luck.
[SPEAKER_03]: My apologies.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, can I stay here for the night?
[SPEAKER_02]: uh she says uh make another make another persuasion she says uh look i really think that that's pushing it don't you i'm sorry i'm gonna leave now thank you for your time
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, I expect to see you by the end of the day tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I will be here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I leave the building.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So where do you go?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're the only one who is not sleeping.
[SPEAKER_03]: What time is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, like, 10 ish, something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys kind of maybe nine, 10, something like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I don't have the courage to go to Biliam, so I'm just gonna go to the bellows and find a spot to hide and sleep in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You head to the bellows, you can take a long rest, and when you wake up you will take one point of exhaustion.
[SPEAKER_03]: Portal art!
[SPEAKER_02]: sleeping on rough on the streets the essentially the sleep in the bellows is not restful and comfortable so uh yeah so i have a question on that did you already had the one point of exhaustion so you have now two what are the effects of the two doing a long rest removes a point of exhaustion uh so she's just back on the one now okay if you get two if you get two during a day then you drop down to one after a long rest it only reduces one point
[SPEAKER_02]: but luckily you were on one you reduced it with a long rest and then gained it back so you're just still on one okay okay but yeah should you receive another one today then it takes two nights of good sleep to remove it so it can be it can build up um but either way you yeah have an event less than restful sleep in the bellows that night and morning rolls around um
[SPEAKER_02]: To begin with, I think we will start with Billy, who wakes up heading to his shift over at Claringbones, even though you do not have a boss or shift to work at.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I'm trying to find out, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You head down there, you locked up the gate on the way out, and you head down there to find it is still locked, arriving at the shift.
[SPEAKER_02]: You go to unlock the gate, open it up, and as you swing it open, you look inside, everything looks normal, deserted, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, as you do that, then you hear behind you a voice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear behind you a voice that says... Let me just find the name of this character.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so sorry, you hear two voices behind you.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are voices you recognize.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are the voices of Alfie and Horace, who work at the scrapyard.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they are employees.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you hear them kind of...
[SPEAKER_02]: walk up behind you as you are unlocking the gate and Alfie is like a young like 19 year old dark and he's quite similar to you he's like probably quite friendly with you normally and then Hollis is a is like about a 50 year old human man who's been working there for a really long time knows shrapnel really well he's got almost the second-in-command sort of thing of the scrapyard for what there is out of a five-man crew Hollis says to you Billy
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh hi, Horace.
[SPEAKER_02]: Horace.
[SPEAKER_05]: Horace.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, did you come in yesterday?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I was going to, but I found nobody here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bad business yesterday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bad business.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then Alfie, who's a little bit excitable, says,
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh man, it was so bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like there was like, like, like there was people that came into the yard and they were like, and they were like threatening and everything and super scary.
[SPEAKER_02]: I like hid straight away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then when we, you know, when I looked up again, like a shrapnel was gone and they'd smashed up the office and they looked really mad.
[SPEAKER_05]: What kind of people were they?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there was like a big woman, big coat, green coat, and there was a guy, he looked super scary, he had like scars across his face, like blonde hair, like... Yeah, yeah, yeah, scary guys, like guild guys, obviously guild guys, but... Well, okay, so was everything, was everyone fine?
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, was anyone injured or...?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like I hid.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I hid in one of the buckets in the corner and then I just came out when everything had stopped and Hollis kind of ducks in and goes like, yeah, Shrapnel told us to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: I headed out back home and he looks kind of ashamed about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Shrapnel saw these guys turn up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think he saw what was the problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: He saw that they were gonna cause a problem and he dismissed all the crew and told us to get out of there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some of us obviously went, but yeah, when we came back, yeah, he was gone.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well then do you think he will be back?
[SPEAKER_05]: today or?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, I doubt it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Given, I mean, he might be dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why would you, why would you say that?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't, I don't think he would be dead if they came to take him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, yeah, maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I'm just saying I wouldn't expect to see him again.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well then...
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna have to do something about that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna find out what happened, and...
[SPEAKER_05]: If you guys could just... look after the scrapyard today, I will...
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll come back tomorrow, and... Make an insight check, Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: I shall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys realise it's very hard to advance the plot when you're shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: When we just are shit inside of anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you gain no information.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, it's fine, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you say that to them.
[SPEAKER_02]: They go, Hollis goes, yeah, yeah, well, I mean, to be honest, we just came to like, see if we can get our wages paid and then get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, no offence to you, Billy, I respect your dedication, but I'm looking for another job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well what about you Alfie?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, like, yeah, let's talk until I come down and maybe we can get some money and then we can get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I gotta work Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't wait around for shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not gonna get paid.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well then, should we just lock up and...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think anyone else you leave it with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're gonna go through and see if there's anything left of it and honestly, uh We gotta get our wages paid and uh get out of here But you can't be taking anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not yours Well, we're owed for we're owed wages aren't we so it is ours kind of Shrapneling in need anymore Well, you don't know that you might be back tomorrow and then then we can
[SPEAKER_02]: work here again then we don't need to find a different job and all should be well look kid you're welcome to think that you're welcome to wait around for as long as you want don't bother me but i'm gonna get in there and see what i can get out of here and then i'm gonna go find another place to work i suggest you do the same you can come in with us if you want or you can get at me wait i appreciate the offer but i'll
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll stay for a bit and figure out what happened to Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so they're gonna, I mean, you're gonna let them walk past you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so they head inside.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see that they head straight to the office and you start to hear like some clanking and tumbling and stuff as they are like searching in the office in general and looking for stuff that they can find.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to do anything
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, no, I'm just going to shout to them to don't forget to lock up and I'll just leave towards the Scrappers where I'm planning to meet up with Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you head over to the Scrappers and plan to meet up with Felix there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other three of you as the morning comes around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys have any particular plans for the day ahead?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, we obviously know that Billy and Felix are heading to the Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you guys said to you, you guys were going to meet Billy like after the shift was over and meet up with everyone again.
[SPEAKER_02]: But are you doing anything sort of just during the day, any plans or anything specific?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I would head to the Plum and Bob to find maybe if Aska is there before we go to the Scrapper.
[SPEAKER_02]: So are you doing anything
[SPEAKER_02]: during the day Asuka or you would just be at the plumb and bob?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Asuka will look into ways to disguise himself seeing as shit is kind of hitting the fan right now Asuka would kind of want to like well he would definitely be more stealthy and try to see if there are any ways that he could disguise himself a little bit
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, uh, yeah, do you have a disguise kit or anything like that in your, uh, I have, let's see, what do I have?
[SPEAKER_02]: This music's something I'm very happy.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I only have, I only have Smith's tool and Tinker's tool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think he would try to acquire a disguise kit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can definitely try and get a disguise kit.
[SPEAKER_02]: at least put one together it is 25 ducats for a full disguise kit kind of expensive yeah if you just buy it felt so sorry how many gold and stuff is that because it's still in gold
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah gold is ducats oh okay so it's 25 it's 25 gold 25 ducats yeah it's uh yeah eska will uh well uh is it is there room for negotiating yes so so that's the base price um that would be like your full kind of like that's paying for like all the cosmetic makeup like fancy like fake beards and fake you know all that all that stuff that's why it's expensive you can certainly make a sort of
[SPEAKER_02]: a hashed together one that would be a lot cheaper probably for like 10 ducats you can make something a lot cheaper.
[SPEAKER_02]: It won't be as effective but will be less expensive or you could just buy a couple of like other outfits for like one ducat that is not going to be anywhere near as effective but will definitely give you some options.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would want the full professional one.
[SPEAKER_02]: full professional 25 ducats spent damn yes cool so you can add a disguise kit i guess you are not proficient in it but as a bard you have like your half proficiency thing so you will still get some bonus when using it but you won't get the full bonus until you're proficient with it um
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to say for this campaign as well, I'm going to put in the similar sort of house rule that we had last time, but with less frills, which is basically if you use something 10 times, I will consider you proficient in it.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you use and succeed in something 10 times.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you use your disguise kit 10 times and you succeed, you will just be proficient in it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But obviously for good reason, you can't just wear it during the day at home.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the tools sheet, I can choose like strength, dex, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so it'll be dex for this, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, everything's set on question mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like smith's tool, dragon chest tool, set sticker tool, that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything's on question mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we need to change any of that?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's basically because there might be times when you would use those with different
[SPEAKER_02]: You might use them with different skills, but for now I wouldn't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And just when we, if you come to use it, I'll tell you what skill to use.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll put it as half, half proficient.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but you will be, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get your half proficiency from your bad stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you are at the Plum and Bob, I guess, coming back from having bought a bunch of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've got shopping bags with fake cosmetic glue and acting paraphernalia and stuff like that in these bags, and you kind of come into the Plum and Bob, and Lark is already in the Plum and Bob as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's no one else here because it's early morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, uh, Lark, hi.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come in, come in.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to put the stuff down, so yeah, walk with me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, um, you probably shouldn't be here for too long anymore, because remember what I told you about Madame Rook?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, did you sell me out?
[SPEAKER_03]: I did not.
[SPEAKER_03]: However,
[SPEAKER_03]: um by tomorrow evening i have to give some sort of information to her because i owe her a debt i mean i am speaking the truth i did not sell you out i'm in the way that you think because it doesn't sound too uh forgive me for saying this but it doesn't sound too convincing
[SPEAKER_03]: I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I did say that the person named Eska was performing here on King's Day, which is the truth, because your name was public.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, the first name was public here on that day.
[SPEAKER_03]: She's smart.
[SPEAKER_03]: She knows that I know you some way and I don't want to give out information about you.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, she said that she's going to send some other people to find you here if I'm not going to give out the information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yes, you weren't lying.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's my name is pretty common around here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, and from what I know of this Madame Rook, she seems to be very good in finding out information one way or another.
[SPEAKER_01]: So right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I thank you for the information.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we will.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will have to I will.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will have to circle around and try not to
[SPEAKER_01]: attract more attention than necessary, which is kind of why I bought these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: She talked about family.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think your family wants to find you.
[SPEAKER_01]: uh yeah it uh i have had run in with uh with uh one of my father's uh enforcer let's uh let's call it that so uh this does not come as a surprise um i'd be i guess before i met you all uh i've had a run in already so
[SPEAKER_01]: yes this seems it seems like my my family or well at least i would not think my father would be behind most of this and uh i think they are really trying to get me so uh this does not come as a surprise no however madame rook i don't think she's she's a bad person or she's standing with any guild specifically and i think she could be maybe
[SPEAKER_03]: useful to us.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am not going to say a liar of any sort, but I'm just saying that she can give out information that she knows if we can give something to her.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I don't know this Madame Roque that you're talking about.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it seems like she is the type to deal with the information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I assume that you came back to her and you, well, let's just say you didn't really give her the information she wanted.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, she wouldn't be here.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I did not give your surname to her or the confirmation.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I also assume that you still need to give her something.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because otherwise she... Well, you said that you have until tomorrow, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, then we better find something to give her today.
[SPEAKER_01]: It could be... May I suggest about... Today, actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: Today evening, because the day was yesterday when she talked to her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sorry, I meant today.
[SPEAKER_01]: I suggest we have to give her something today then.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we are already on the track of something about Porcher's Guild because, well, they have roughed up me, they have roughed up Theo and probably, and assumably the Scrapyard worker, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: I already said to her that... Porcher's Guild is up to something.
[SPEAKER_03]: I hope we could maybe get something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it is our best lead for now.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, from what I can assume, she will not really accept any information unless it's really crucial information that she can make use of.
[SPEAKER_01]: So she will not accept it if we come to her with just the assumptions and the fact that the Portis Guild might be behind this.
[SPEAKER_01]: We really do need some concrete information to give her.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: But Eska, what if I told you that it was you in the bar?
[SPEAKER_03]: What would happen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that would mean I would no longer be able to stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that would also mean that I might not see any of you again.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, then that's not gonna happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'd rather give my own head to her than yours.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, let's hope it doesn't come to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Insight check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe you, however, let's hope that it doesn't come to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And while I appreciate the gesture, let's just say I hope it doesn't get to that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's for now find some information.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just not a good liar and if I did try to lie I think we all would be in way bigger trouble.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I understand and it's probably better for you not to lie to someone like Madame Rourke because she will probably find out one way or another that you're lying to her.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's better to give the truth and let's be honest, if it comes down to that, it's still better for you to give her the information she needs rather than at the cost of your own head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, so I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, let's just see if we can get some concrete information to deliver to her so that you don't have to put me or yourself in danger.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: So was Felix going to come here today, or to... No, Felix is meeting with Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going with Billy to the other...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Kyle is coming, but I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Should we wait for him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Calder... Calder, did you say that you were going to meet us here or did you...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we agreed that we meet here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you agreed to meet after the sort of shift for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whether you go earlier during the day is up to you, but it depends if you've got something else you want to do, Calder, before that.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah i don't remember what we what we agreed yeah maybe i think we agreed after yeah yeah yeah we because you because you're still working you're still working yeah okay so okay so yeah yeah you have until like i think we said like three p.m or something when billy shift normally ends on this on on a looms day which we are now in then uh you can go and meet them at the plum bob after they've spoken to the fixed field scrappers but if you want to do anything during the day
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Same question, I guess, if you want to do anything, let me know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I will, but are Iskahn and Lark done?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think they kind of concluded their conversation, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so then I think I would start the day with the typical working a little bit, you know, doing the research, etc., etc., making notes to my notebook.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I think I would
[SPEAKER_00]: change my clothes again to put the disguise on and then I would go to the underground to meet my crew, so to say.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hold up, what's going on here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, donning your disguise and assuming your sort of persona, you head to the
[SPEAKER_02]: You head to the bellows, to underground, to where you most often meet your crewmates.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you would probably have some sort of method of... You don't have any sending spells or anything like that, right, Calder?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not the sending spell.
[SPEAKER_00]: I now know message spell, but it's different.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you would have some sort of method.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe it's just like leaving a particular mark or leaving a sort of note or something like that that would tell them to meet there because they're not just like hanging around in the bellows the whole time waiting for someone to turn up.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you arrange a meeting basically and you get head down to the bellows to meet your two crewmates who are Dunmore and Penn.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will just put us in the bellows first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have to double check the names as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we'll use this one.
[SPEAKER_02]: So in the sort of generic part of the bellows, you head down there and, yeah, you have a certain meeting place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Man, why can't I get these to work?
[SPEAKER_02]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys see these pictures?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, no, you won't because they're set to coldest.
[SPEAKER_02]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you head down and meet these two guys, Dunmore, this like very big muscular guy, and then Penn, a much smaller kind of younger ratty kind of little bit ratty looking kid as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: You turn up and they're kind of like just chatting amongst themselves as you arrive.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just keep, if they're back up behind me, I just keep, you know, walking basically behind them and then I put my hands on their shoulders.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then one goes, oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Mr. C, how's it going?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's been a while.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would need you guys to do something for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, no worries.
[SPEAKER_02]: We got you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm starting to get involved into something, but I would need more information on the target, so to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would want you guys to split up to gather a little bit info, whatever you can gather up.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think pen, I think if you can go and keep eye on the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, what was the name?
[SPEAKER_00]: What was the name?
[SPEAKER_00]: Volant building.
[SPEAKER_00]: And see what is going on over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is any people going inside?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is people coming outside?
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't need to go inside the building.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I tell the description where the building is and how it looks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, in the outlines, is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, Dunmore, I would want you to do a little bit more on the footwork, but also gathering information on the guild... What was the guild name again?
[SPEAKER_03]: Quarters or Engineers?
[SPEAKER_00]: The...
[SPEAKER_00]: Big Lady and the scary man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Porter's Guild, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought there were some sub guilds on that, no?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, they're like official guildies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, and then you were the one of the sub.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Brassline is like affiliated with them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, okay, yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, again... Oh, sorry, you go on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have heard that they have taken some person into custody.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you have any way to ask people around if this is true, what happened to him, where they are holding him, that would be extremely handy.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can ask around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hold it.
[SPEAKER_00]: As soon as I found it inside.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can tell that Dunmore is a little shifty about the request, I guess, or a little nervous about the request.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he just says, yeah, he's going to do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But yeah, you don't need to.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't need to poke too much or, you know, you don't need to go inside the guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be too dangerous, too risky.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, you know, you can just keep going the perihelior over there and see what's going on and then keep asking the underground as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So some someone's held there in the tower, you think?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I believe the name was...
[SPEAKER_00]: Definitely not Killermant.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's his name?
[SPEAKER_02]: Barry, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I guess there's two people that you suspect might be held at the Porter's Guild, Spyre, which is both Barry Killermant and Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: And, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, two people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two people, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, right, right, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just like, yeah, Askaran and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, boss, the thing is, with the Porter's Guild, right, I don't know if you know, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: like a lot of the Porter's Guild is pretty let's say mixed up with a lot you know the
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know what you call it, the underworld.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: But like, I just mean like, a lot of the Porter's Guild's got a reputation, not like with the Guild of Engineers, they're all prim and proper, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't deal with us, with us folks who operate slightly around the law.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the Porter's Guild, they got some folks who are a lot more
[SPEAKER_02]: willing to bend the rules on when it comes to strict laws and city policy and that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So problem is with looking into them is a lot of people what deal in these sort of circles have their own connections to the Porter's Guild as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm just saying it might cause a bit of a stink if we start asking around too much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Before you should know, you know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be very handy to know the locations or get any hint of the location of these two persons and whether they are even alive anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, what I can tell you is, you know, the Head of Steam?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a pub out next to the Furlong.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think you would have necessarily heard of it before.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says it's the Porter's Guild
[SPEAKER_02]: haunt like the hangout for them is owned by an ex porters guild guy um big pub lots of porters guild guys go there it's sort of like their number one you know like almost like a clubhouse for the guild if you know what i mean if you want some information on porters guild you might want to head there ain't no no use me and pal going there because of we we're known faces you know in in the
[SPEAKER_02]: the scene man we need a better name for our criminal underground but uh yeah i mean yeah clearly criminal yeah um we need a better name for our like uh for our
[SPEAKER_02]: for our outfit down here but uh look the porters guild guys they they they hang out at this place head to steam a lot and if you want some info and you can get in you can get in there and maybe chat to some of them uh that might be a way to go i'm just saying uh you're the boss yeah can you can you spell the name to the to the chat what was the yeah let me write in the chat for you boss yeah yeah thank you head of steam okay
[SPEAKER_05]: All right, all right.
[SPEAKER_00]: But yeah, I'll do my own investigations and you do what you can as well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Ben's task is a little bit easier, yeah, and should be more safe as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, no worries, boss.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we'll get on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, remember Gotham City needs you.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you read Batman with every single... Yo, what the hell, man?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a massive guy, like, dealing, you know, behind the scenes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just putting the Googles in and then, you know... Where's the Superman?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, no, uh, yeah, no, he says, uh, yeah, no worries.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll, um, yeah, we'll let you... How, uh, what's the way to get word to you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, normal way?
[SPEAKER_02]: Drop?
[SPEAKER_02]: You got some special situation?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nah, you can...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, the normal normal way is fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just drop the litter in here.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll leave the job.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I
[SPEAKER_00]: leave way cooler way than I left in the first time if you remember it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah you kind of like slip off into a tunnel as they can continue walking on as if you were never there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I go up and change my clothes, put them on my backpack and just happily start to walk throughout the pub.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So meanwhile, over on the other side of town, in Fexfield Scrappers or nearby to it, I guess, we'll say Billy and Felix, you sort of meet outside the Scrappers, knowing that both of you are supposed to be there first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, I think you've been there a bit longer, so you can make a perception check for me, just that you've been sort of hanging out outside and listening and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice, well at least Felix can roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear a constant like noise coming from inside of a heavily working factory slash scrapping operation that is clearly working normally and basically it's not deserted or abandoned like the like claring bones you can tell as there is actually
[SPEAKER_02]: work going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you see Billy sort of turn up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now this building is like rather than a yard like Claring Bones, it's a big warehouse with a front facing door with a sign above it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I said, a lot more professional than Claring Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it has, and it has Fexfield Scrappers written in a sign across the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's all very sort of bit more prim, proper, organized, professional, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you guys are right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello, Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hi.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was at the scrapyard this morning just to check what's going on.
[SPEAKER_05]: I met a few of my colleagues.
[SPEAKER_05]: They told me a little bit about what happened, but it's basically as we thought that
[SPEAKER_05]: They came for shrapnel and they took him and then they smashed the place.
[SPEAKER_05]: But at least all the other ones, my colleagues are fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: They weren't injured.
[SPEAKER_05]: But it looks like shrapnel isn't going to be back soon.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: If we go in here, I think it would be good that
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I would pretend to be looking for a new job, but I'm not sure how much we should say about what happened with Shrepnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you think about that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's not really talk about what happened there at Shrepnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, we're going to need some kind of an excuse, I think.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, as to why we would, I don't know if you feel like you would also pretend that you want to get a job here or.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I do need a job show.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we don't really have to lie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, but also we should try to figure out if something happened here.
[SPEAKER_05]: or if maybe they have different associations and maybe that's the reason that something did not happen here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know any people that work here at all?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I think we might have to find someone, like we can't just ask anybody, we need to find someone who's a bit
[SPEAKER_05]: higher up, perhaps?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, that will be the smallest thing I think.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I guess William would start looking at this building and it's a lot bigger, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's like an entire area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a big warehouse basically with probably a yard out back and stuff as well, but the main big brick building, two, three stories tall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And is there like a gate where it would be like a normal entrance?
[SPEAKER_02]: It looks like the normal entrance is the door on the front for anyone coming, you know, presumably they get customers and stuff who might just walk in like people looking for stuff or work done.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you guess like the employee entrance would be at the back through the yard or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You wouldn't normally go in through the front if you're an employee.
[SPEAKER_05]: And what do you think, Felix, should we just go into the front and ask for someone to talk to about getting a job here?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I think that's the best plan for now.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, let's go then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're walking through the front door and you come into the interior, which, yeah, you see this big open space, very organized.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's so different to you, Billy, compared to what you're used to at Claring Burns, which is like piles of shit everywhere and everybody kind of just doing their own thing and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not that bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this is definitely way more organized.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everything is kind of like racked out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's tools and machines being scrapped out and everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's plenty of people working here as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as you walk in, one of the guys who is just like near the door, a really big guy with a kind of apron on, which I can, turns around to look at you and goes,
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: How can I help you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Ah, good morning.
[SPEAKER_05]: Morning.
[SPEAKER_05]: My name is William.
[SPEAKER_05]: Me and my friend here were trying to see if we could work here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is there anyone we could talk to about that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aye, Scrappy's are here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you can make a deception check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, is Felix dressed currently?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think Felix's clothes definitely look a lot nicer than the average scrapyard worker.
[SPEAKER_02]: But with the 16, he either kind of looks you over a little bit, Felix, and goes, all right, well, we always need people down here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess you can go see the boss.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lucille, she's up the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: He kind of points you towards kind of the back office area.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, Lucille, that's, that's the name I heard before as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh, thanks.
[SPEAKER_05]: And thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: We'll make our way to that place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You walk through head upstairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and, um, you see like, it's more of a workshop up here than an office, but you see a woman is working in the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: I say as I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very small.
[SPEAKER_01]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Woman's working in the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of looks up as you two arrive, kind of standing slightly sheepishly outside the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: The door's open, but she's like working away on something.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then she realizes you're standing there and she goes, hey, don't stand at the door, come in.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, we...
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, my name is Billy, uh, Billy and, um, this is Felix.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we were wondering if you're looking for more people in employment.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, she, she kind of looks you both over and just sort of says like, I always need more people here, but, uh, you lot got any previous experience?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah, I've been working at another factory for a few years now, or well, yeah, I think it was a few years.
[SPEAKER_05]: You don't seem sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, it's just, you know, time flies by.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I've also worked at the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm a highly trained individual.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am what scrapyard was it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: It was a Claring Bones yard, actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: How's it going?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, we've had some ups and downs, but, you know, the scrapyard is still running.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a deception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Decision.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's so suspicious.
[SPEAKER_02]: How are you doing?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty good.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's still running.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nod.
[SPEAKER_02]: Definitely still operating.
[SPEAKER_02]: If I had to say one thing about it, it would be that it's operating normally.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a believable lie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Surely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think she's just actually going to make the inside check in this case.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, well, good to hear Shrapnel's a good lad.
[SPEAKER_02]: We do a bit of work together, me and him, so it's always good to see another man.
[SPEAKER_02]: What about you?
[SPEAKER_02]: She points at you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't look like no scrappy I've ever seen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I've mostly done paperwork, but I just really need a job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aye, that's fair, that's fair.
[SPEAKER_02]: How are you with numbers and that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I can work with numbers, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: How many numbers do you know?
[SPEAKER_04]: How many do you want to know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell me all the numbers that you know in order.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, are you all right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's always good to have options, you know, we never really, you know, I'm Lisa, by the way, sorry about the, you know,
[SPEAKER_02]: frosty recession and that but we get a lot of chances come in here everybody wants a job and it's not easy to separate the wheat from the from the chaff whatever wheat is we don't have wheat in the city so that wouldn't make sense as a idiom but you know what I mean could I ask you something Lucille?
[SPEAKER_05]: Which guild are you associated with?
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_02]: this campaign is just like oh it's on difficult mode you know yeah i i think i think we've never had this much ones in any of our campaigns i can't remember any significant natural 20s but no uh yeah with the with the natural ones she says um yeah look especially don't talk really about the guilds around here because
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, not so many people here necessarily talk about that kind of stuff and make it public.
[SPEAKER_02]: You probably know from Claring Bones that the Core Rights Association is normally the people what we're supposed to pay our dues to.
[SPEAKER_02]: The best you don't know about, the little you know about that, the better.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was just asking because if it's, you know, if it's the core writer association, then, you know, I'd be familiar with that.
[SPEAKER_05]: So it just, you know, make work easier if, if, if I know what's different and, you know, what's the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, look, none of that really needs to be your business.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you work in here, you know, like that's for sort of upper management.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just get your work done and don't worry too much about the guilds, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are there any vacancies in upper management?
[SPEAKER_02]: She looks you up and down a little bit and she goes, look, me and my brother run this place, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been in a family business for a long time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm obviously fixed field, it's on the door and
[SPEAKER_02]: we really think we're doing pretty well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of gestures around to everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of the ways we got about that is by keeping it in the family, keeping things, you know, keeping it with people that we know, you know, and no offense to you like, but I don't know, you're from Adam, you just walked in off the street.
[SPEAKER_02]: So maybe once you've had a bit of experience here, but I'm sure some of the boys down in the yard would be fighting for you, fighting you if you suddenly turned around and, you know, got a promotion before you'd even had a day's work.
[SPEAKER_05]: I, is that, is fighting allowed here?
[SPEAKER_02]: She sort of laughs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, uh, no, I think you're missing the point.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the point is here really like, uh,
[SPEAKER_02]: Why, I don't know anything about you too.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could be guilt spies coming in, trying to get information on me business.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could be, who knows who you could be from a rival yard, like Claring Bones trying to work out how we best work contracts and that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am from Claring Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I've got no reason to trust you at this point.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, that's fair.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm slightly offended by that, but okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um,
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, maybe this is not the place for me then, but maybe Felix, I know he's a good guy, so I think he would fit in pretty well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like we could always use a guy who can do the books and that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And look, if you want to start at the bottom of the ranks, you know, you want to start at the bottom of the rung and get a job.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, we can talk about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you're asking questions about the gilding that you start to rile me up the wrong way.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, I didn't mean to do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just, I'm naturally curious about a lot of things.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I, maybe I, I just ask a bit too much.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what they told me very often while I was working that I, I talk and I ask a bit too much, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, uh, look, I don't mind you talking to that tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I like a friendly guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it's, it's all right, but, uh, just, uh, I don't know, like no offense to you, but, uh, you look like you're coming in with an ulterior motive than just getting work.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I, um, might actually, you know what?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think you're right.
[SPEAKER_05]: I, um,
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I do want work, but look, you said you were on good terms with Shrapnel, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, when I kind of look around, start acting a bit suspicious, he was taken from the art yesterday by some people from the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was trying to figure out why and to where and how, and I was hoping I could find out about that maybe from here.
[SPEAKER_02]: She sort of walks past both of you and closes the door and says, so like, you two
[SPEAKER_02]: You know anything about, uh, about his like, about Shrapnel's like, uh, uh, she's like looking for, looking for a phrase to use, um, like his extra work that he does?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's just say there's a couple of contracts that probably keep off the books a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: A couple of things that he deals with that you probably wouldn't find him writing down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that ringing any bells to you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I mean, that was the one thing I was told not to ask questions about.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I know he was always running stuff behind the scenes.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, yeah, and he just, he had to do what he has to do, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: As the manager of the place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, look like, uh, thing is like, like he had a couple of deals with, uh, let's say some friends of ours and, uh,
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, we have mutual friends, me and him, and some of that works pretty lucrative, makes a lot of extra cash on the side, but try and keep that kind of thing away from people like the Korite Guild, for example, because they probably take a big fat percentage of the pay if that sort of stuff comes out.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_05]: That actually makes a lot of sense, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why would the Porter's Guild be then getting involved if it's just a core rights association that would take the... Well, since you know it's got something to do with the Porter's Guild, they're the clients.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're the ones we're selling to.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the core rights guilds we're trying to keep it from because they'll take a big percentage, like I said, but if they find out that we're doing this sort of stuff,
[SPEAKER_02]: We?
[SPEAKER_02]: Me and Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, I thought just Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: I see.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, shit, now I've got to kill you.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's a joke, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a joke.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, like, yeah, like, look,
[SPEAKER_02]: The fact that Shrapnel's been taken away is pretty concerning to me because that sounds like something's gone wrong.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, we've got to be pretty big operation here and I'm not too scared about a couple of Porter's Guild louts coming around.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had two this morning trying to ask questions and that to us, but we just got rid.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm not too worried about... Was it a big lady and a blonde guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it was.
[SPEAKER_04]: You know him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, there's people that took Shrepnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, yeah, look.
[SPEAKER_02]: Them... Those guys are the ones that, let's say, broke the deal for the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: They come here and they pick up the merchandise and they make the payments.
[SPEAKER_02]: And...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm guessing that shrapnel couldn't deliver.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I don't know nothing about your situation, but if that's why, if he's disappeared and they came in and took him, then that's probably the, that's probably the reason, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, do you know anything that we
[SPEAKER_02]: could do to, you know, get him back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you're going up against a big guild there.
[SPEAKER_02]: The thing with Porter's Guild is they do a lot of, like, deals below, you know, outside the books.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they got a lot of dangerous people.
[SPEAKER_02]: that'll do work for them and uh it's not a good idea to just the two of yous go up and try and cause problems with a girl like that they'll uh knock you out as soon as they uh you know before they even talk to you but if he's been held anywhere it'd be in the Porter's Guild spire and good luck getting in there yeah it's it would be tough but I don't want to give up on Shrepnel
[SPEAKER_05]: Hey, I respect that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I respect that, Lou.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can both make persuasion checks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go on, go on.
[SPEAKER_05]: I might use a Tides of Chaos here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whoa.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let me check how that... where on my sheep...
[SPEAKER_05]: Yo.
[SPEAKER_05]: This one.
[SPEAKER_05]: And just get a...
[SPEAKER_05]: Advantage.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, nice.
Jesus.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's with your roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my goodness.
[SPEAKER_01]: We cannot roll for shits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that a four and a five?
[SPEAKER_02]: God.
[SPEAKER_02]: Normally I'm the one who are all shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: She kind of looks at you Billy and you've been doing most of the talking obviously a little nervously and she looks over at Felix and she says like I think you look like you might be a little bit more put together no offense kid but uh situation is that uh if they got your man Scrapnel and uh you want to get him back maybe you can trade for him
[SPEAKER_02]: Seems like he didn't deliver.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you've got the goods they want, then maybe they'll just trade him back for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I presume you ain't got the goods that they want because you probably wouldn't be here if you did.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there's just one thing I don't understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: If they want money, wouldn't it be stupid to, like,
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you're, you're not, I don't think you're following.
[SPEAKER_02]: They pay money.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't need money.
[SPEAKER_02]: They need the cause.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the cause.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can't get money.
[SPEAKER_02]: They got plenty.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there's only a few of these.
[SPEAKER_02]: She kind of like hesitates, realizing she's maybe like saying a little bit too much, but she says, there's only like, let's say it's a limited supply of this particular merchandise that they want.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so if Shrapnel ain't delivered his part, the bargain, they can't get it anywhere else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm not really following.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know what?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think, you know, like I said, Felix is, you said it yourself, he's way more put together.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will go home and think about this and feel free to talk to Felix more, but yeah, maybe it's not the right place for me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you for your hospitality.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's been nice to meet you.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, nice to meet you, kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, you need a job down here.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's work for scrapers if you can scrap.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, you come back, all right?
[SPEAKER_02]: But until then.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right, I might do that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You take care of Shrapnel, all right?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a good guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll try, I'll try.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why then?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, I still do need a job, actually, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, you seem like, like I said, you seem like you're a little bit more put together.
[SPEAKER_02]: No offence to your friend or wherever you found him.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, we can always use someone who can look over the books, like maybe, you know, work out some of the, you know, me and my brother run this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe you met him down there and she kind of plays down.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah yeah yeah but like our father used to run it and you know it's it's tricky running a business knowing how you you know knowing all the accounts and all that sort of stuff is not the most straightforward so maybe we can find somewhere for you to put in some work I can do this perfect perfect all right
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, look, yeah, you stay here for a bit and I'll run through some of these books and stuff with you and you can maybe give me an idea of how you might be able to help.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure, that sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a natural one.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think make a history municipality check for me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kunda.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kunda, indeed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah yes, a Gunther check.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, advantage on that one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Time to throw two ones then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quite, but you made sure all above a 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: 13 again, my third 13.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you spent some kind of like, going through some of the books with her and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you're able to point out like, this is quite similar stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make also an investigation check.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is going to be a pretty high DC.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not going to be enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't find anything kind of particularly interesting in the books as you go through them.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's obviously not going to show you the secretive stuff or whatever like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you do think that in this position, you may in the future be able to get some extra information perhaps.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you are not able to get it straight away.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you start to work through some of the books with her.
[SPEAKER_02]: She goes, um, you know, after a couple of hours, I guess, Billy, you sort of head back towards the Plum and Bob, but after a couple of hours, she goes, um, all right.
[SPEAKER_02]: She, you know, your stuff, uh, well enough, like, uh, maybe turn up tomorrow and, uh, maybe you can do like a bit of an audit in that and check out what we've, what we've got here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe find some ways to save some money for us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, always, always worth having.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, all right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pleasure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, Felix was it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perfect, perfect, all right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we'll see you tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll see you tomorrow then.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she, yeah, lets you head off and the five of you through eventual blah, blah, blah come back together and arrive back at the Pum and Bub.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, congrats, Felix, you got a job, yay!
[SPEAKER_03]: Can we have a quick...
[SPEAKER_04]: Most unemployable, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Meeting again.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, we're back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Back from... Just a little break.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got some water left.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: A few new developments and so on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so we had to come back.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the next time we played, it wasn't much further.
[SPEAKER_01]: So much earlier.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the story is still fresh.
[SPEAKER_01]: But jeez, we really can't roll today.
[SPEAKER_01]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just threw my first natural one.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if I just look at what's being thrown, holy shit, this is so bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, [Felix], this is one of the first times you've thrown it right.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the hell.
[SPEAKER_01]: If everyone does it wrong, you just do it right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't believe it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's so bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: [Lark] has been throwing under the 10 all the time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything she threw was under the 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: The persuasion check was a natural one.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a 5?
[SPEAKER_01]: An 8.
[SPEAKER_01]: Under the 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another persuasion check under the 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Man, man, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: [stream chat, muted]
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you really threw 3x13 or something, but... Yeah, I didn't throw that much, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Except the inside check was good, but my stealth check was really... Yeah, natural one.
[SPEAKER_01]: The first natural one.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I didn't really throw that much, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: [stream chat, muted]
[SPEAKER_01]: You're pulling everyone together on average.
Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, after this.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, all right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the five of you come back together in the sort of late afternoon in the Plum and Bob.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So how did it go at the new, at the other scrapyard?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I got a job there now, doing all the paperwork.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, we also had some information.
[SPEAKER_05]: We talked to the manager of the facility, Lucille Vexfield, and she knows Shrapnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: She kind of works with him, and she thinks that Shrapnel was taken because he might not have delivered
[SPEAKER_05]: his not delivered upon his promises to the uh porters guild and that maybe they took him because of that so sounds like some shady business has gone wrong it must be a it must be about the essence then this is what we
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can piece together the clues that we have, there's some machine parts with essence were delivered to both scrapyards.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it seems that the Porter's Guild is really looking for information regarding these essence.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, they seem to be quite desperate to get those cores.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we see what they can do, then I can understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: These cores have killed a man and well, almost got the three of you killed.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it must be something very important then.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And so I thought that the murder of Theodore was their plan, but maybe it's just a small part of it if they still need more weapons or more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we don't, we don't know who murdered Theodore.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't know their motives yet, but we know that.
[SPEAKER_05]: We know it was someone from a guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that the people that are trying to cover it up seem to be
[SPEAKER_05]: Either from the Guild of Engineering or the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_05]: So they must be in cahoots of some sort.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a theory that the people at the Guild of Engineers are behind the murder of Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, the Porter's Guild are basically just looking for ways to improve on their situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in this case, it's with their essence.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they are just digging into how they can get their hands on as much essence as possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: In any case, that's what I can deduce from what you gave me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seeing as they've been going to scrap yards for Machineries that well are basically tossed aside because they are tossed aside so I think what they were trying to do is to gather those machinery and
[SPEAKER_01]: trying to build up some kind of weapon of their own maybe because it seems like they're dealing in secondhand scrap basically and they're the ones paying for these things and let's be honest here this is probably not on the books kind of deals as it is but
[SPEAKER_05]: You sure know a lot about all this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I used to be in the Guild of Engineers, so these cores are kind of...
[SPEAKER_01]: I know what these cores are, I know what they can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think, Billy, you remember that Shrapnel specifically told you that the cores in this particular prototype machine that they scrapped down were
[SPEAKER_02]: better than regular essence cores.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, regular essence cores on their own are useful and powerful and stuff, but these were premium cores, premium new, you know, this is a prototype machine with new technology in it that made these cores more useful, more valuable than normal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to tell that or not?
[SPEAKER_02]: He did mention it previously.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just reminding you guys, generally.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you were in this graveyard, he did mention that before as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would it be like... Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, for example, the howls that we encountered, would those be easily run on the normal course or would those need more premium ones?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, for you, Calder, this is brand new information.
[SPEAKER_02]: there is only one type of essence core that exists as far as any of you know, up until Billy informing you that shrapnel said that these were some kind of new technology.
[SPEAKER_02]: Essence cores are basically just like a battery, which is a way of holding electricity, and this is like someone telling you about lithium-ion batteries when all you ever know about is normal batteries, like suddenly these much more powerful, much more useful batteries now exist.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so yeah, as far as you're concerned, like normally howls would run on
[SPEAKER_02]: run with a core and normally it would take like one essence core is enough to power like a bully boy or a howl or something like that right they they have quite a lot of power within a single core that's why they're so expensive so for Billy to strip down a machine that had 10 cores and those 10 cores are even more you know that's like it's like a nuclear reactor right it's maybe not quite like that level but like the serious power that is like seemingly on like
[SPEAKER_02]: You have no knowledge for what use all of that power is, but clearly that's a big deal, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And I guess, Colder, even without you having to make a roll, the howls that you saw in the tunnels were definitely faster and quicker and more dangerous than a regular howl, so you could probably assume that they had a better core than a normal howl, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would want to then bring this also to the table and then wondering like okay so if they are taking like what they took 15 and then 30 or something like that what were the numbers 50 cause 50 I mean there was a number 50 and a number 30 from yeah so yeah I mean
[SPEAKER_00]: Either, I mean, they could hypothetically be building some massive machine or bomb that taking everything, or they can be making like an army of those fast owls.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, that would be horrendous.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and seeing as these cores are, well, also new to me, I've never seen them before.
[SPEAKER_01]: When I was at the Guild of Engineering, we only deal with normal cores and not anything of this proportion right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then, I'm guessing, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: First of all, I'm guessing it's just- Aski, you can make, sorry, make an engineering check as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Engineering.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just to have a look and see if there's maybe some more- Hey, a good roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, damn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whoa.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys do knowledge rolls quite good.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just don't do acting on the knowledge rolls very well.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 22, yeah, like you know of, I mean, obviously you know of various projects that were going on at the Guild of Engineers that you were not privy to yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like you are obviously being prepped, but you know that things were going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like if you remember back in sort of the one-on-one that we did where
[SPEAKER_02]: you know you you kind of found some of these research areas where people were doing research on stuff so the end the guild of engineers is very much focused on scientific advancement basically just trying to create the you know exploit technology and make the best the most possible advances they can so
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not so surprising to you that they've actually managed to get something useful.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you never heard of anything particularly useful coming out, but they were always trying to like innovate and create new things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, obviously.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, this is probably one of their successful projects that they have created.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then Aska would say, can I ask you something then?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I know that essence cores are basically created by collecting essence and somehow harnessing that energy.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wouldn't that be also made by the College of Arcanographers or just the engineers that make the cores?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just going to say this in Crimson, you can correct me if I'm wrong.
[SPEAKER_01]: But well, from my knowledge, the engineers are the ones who make the core.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, not specifically the core right association.
[SPEAKER_02]: core right being as in like a ship right or a heart right somebody that makes cause the core right association the sub faction sort of thing of the guild of engineers have really specifically are the ones that make cause and that's that is a highly classified secret that even the guild event they won't share that necessarily even with the guild of engineers that much i mean you would expect that the higher-ups in the guild of engineers know how to do it but
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, like the core rights main thing is like we can make these cores and that's our like our niche, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the expertise is in the core of engineers, but of course, like the higher up guild of engineers generally would probably know that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so then I don't know if Eska would have been given that information.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think I think everyone knows that the Core Right Association, everyone who knows something about the guilds knows that the Core Right Association makes cores.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just like you would know the, you know, the Artificers Guild makes tools or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it's yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that part is known.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, for my knowledge, the core rights associations are the ones who make the course.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, and this would probably explain the relationship between my father and your father.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would assume that
[SPEAKER_01]: the college has a hand in helping developing these course to see seeing as they are working on advancements of making the course more efficient making the course stronger and well
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that you could have seen when fighting those hounds, that they were faster, they were much better than the hounds that you've seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is probably the result of the cooperation between the college and the guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably you can make an arcana, arcanographer check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh shit, you're plus eight on that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, this is your field of expertise, kind of, I mean, not specifically cause, but you, you imagine from what you know of the guild that, or of the college that, that is, that doesn't seem as likely as it might sound because for them it's like,
[SPEAKER_02]: the cores are seen as a kind of means to an end as opposed to the original
[SPEAKER_02]: interesting part which is like the essence itself if that makes sense like the college studies magic and cores are just like a box to put magic in so they're not that they don't tend to work on like the technological side of things it doesn't mean that that's out of the question what the kind of the theory the theory and stuff that you guys are discussing but it seems to you that there's probably something that's more
[SPEAKER_02]: If the college is involved there's probably something more beyond like let's just make a better version of existing technology like the college is more about like the big picture ideas the theoretical magic the like the larger picture rather than like helping to make better batteries basically that would just be an engineering thing you know so you think that there's probably something more beyond just like let's make better cores because that's not really like
[SPEAKER_02]: people in the college wouldn't be that interested in that generally.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's more of an engineer's type of thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I bring this up for the conversation as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because over at the table I would have also thought in the similar way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's what I thought as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well.
[SPEAKER_05]: So maybe
[SPEAKER_05]: these improved essence scores.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're either made by someone who has plans for them, or maybe they were made and then kind of falling into wrong hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I assume that- Yeah, Billy, I think
[SPEAKER_02]: You understand that the machine in the scrapyard that you scrapped was described to you as a prototype, as in a attempt to make something that obviously didn't work properly and was then scrapped.
[SPEAKER_02]: which somehow found its way to Claring Bones Yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't imagine the way that Shrapnel described it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't imagine it was supposed to be scrapped by Claring Bones because this is like highly, highly classified technology and shit, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Somehow this got to like a normal scrap yard in the city and that seems to be Theo's doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: to get that prototype machine to Claring Bones and presumably to Fexfield as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't think that that's the plan from the engineers to like, oh, we've made this great technology, but it doesn't work very well, just throw it out the back and let the scrapyards have it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clearly, there's like some plot involved there to get it to the scrapyards.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that seems to be where Theo is linked to any of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's what I was thinking as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Too many puzzle pieces.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little puzzle clue.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark says, are we now sure that this new essence power is certified information currently and not many people, even in the guilds, know it, you think?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I would definitely say you're muted.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're muted.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, did I mute myself?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, Eska would like jump in on this and say, well, I can tell you for sure that especially with the
[SPEAKER_01]: with the information about the more powerful cores, they are definitely not information that are available on the, well, in any case, for the public.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it seems that this was the whole idea of the
[SPEAKER_01]: new more powerful course was the reason why Theo was killed and it was also the reason why shrapnel was taken and also the reason why the porters guild are basically running amok looking for information on Theo I think
[SPEAKER_01]: We basically found our source of the problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody seems to be looking for these cores.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Felix, I would definitely say, I think your, well, now boss is definitely withholding more information than she actually knows.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would suggest while working for her, you see if you could find any information.
[SPEAKER_01]: In any case, regarding to these cores and the 50 that was supposed to go to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yeah, it seems like you have a really good position to find out more information about that and see what you can pry from the boss as well, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just, you know, getting a good grace and maybe...
[SPEAKER_01]: Her brother, maybe her brother as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ask her if she knows she has a brother.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just try to get into her good grace and get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Lark, it seems I think that you have your information to give to Madame Rue.
[SPEAKER_01]: That does not concern me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just I don't know how much she already knows.
[SPEAKER_03]: It would be kind of good to get a name from Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_03]: someone who is sort of in charge there looking for this essence now, someone who's desperate to keep it because then Madame Rook would have some information against them, you know, that would be valuable for her to keep.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just mean that we don't have any names from the Portuguese guild.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and then I think Calder would want them to hop in at this point and ask Lark that, do you know a place called Head of Steam?
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you heard?
[SPEAKER_02]: Would have heard of it, because it is a Porter's Guild haunt and many crews and Porter's Guild people would go there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't think Lark's necessarily ever been there, but certainly higher ups people like Mira might go there occasionally to meet other Porter Guild crew heads and stuff as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I heard that name and I heard that there could be people, high-end people going over there, so maybe we could get some
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, some names from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think the problem would be to go inside over there and then... Well, yeah, I certainly cannot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grimmson would ask her to know about the pub and have actually performed there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you probably heard of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think you would have performed that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think there is no music.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't have like a live music element to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's more of a sort of like clubhouse or like a, you know, like a working men's club type of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like a, it's mostly about drinking.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think you've heard that there are games played there, like, like gambling type of games that are done there quite often as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: As for your, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, okay, yeah, yeah, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think make a...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think all of you make municipality checks for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just really like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: The new check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why are we rolling for Will now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, Billy's still not, don't worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, certainly Billy would not know anything about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: That makes sense anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aska, yeah, knowing about pubs and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark would know a little bit about it as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder knows about it because he's the one who's heard about it as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's a very busy, large establishment where you feel like
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: It depends if you think that many people in the Porter's Guild are in on the scheme, in which case going there would be dangerous.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, if it is only so far the people that you've met from the Porter's Guild are only two, there's only two people, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Porter's Guild are talking about like thousands and thousands of people, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: If those two people happen to be there, they will obviously recognize you, but the majority of the Portis Guild are just people working like you, Lark, like they probably don't have any... they probably don't care about any of this.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, there is some risk, but there's risk about going anywhere in the city with you guys being potentially hunted in various ways, whether it's Asger or whether it's Lark or whoever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, I don't think it's as dangerous as you think it is to go there, given everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably no more dangerous than the Plum and Bob.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you guys are currently in the Plum and Bob, which is definitely more dangerous because you've been linked to this pub multiple times at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: I do repeat myself that this should be the last night we are here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should find a new place where we could meet
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, it seems that Shrepto isn't coming back to this crapyard and there shouldn't be anyone else there.
[SPEAKER_05]: All the guys left already.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we could meet up there.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not really a comfortable place, but it's a place.
[SPEAKER_03]: I thought it was nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can see that it's a good place to meet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: To you, Kroosin, is there...
[SPEAKER_05]: Like a back entrance or something to the scrapyard that I know of?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think probably not because it is basically like a yard between There's three buildings on the side and then one side faces the road So those buildings probably don't have doors into the yard because they had separate businesses So there is probably just that one entrance at the front
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, well, we can meet at the shipyard next time.
[SPEAKER_05]: So what's our plan?
[SPEAKER_05]: What do we want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: What time is it now, Kirsten?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's coming up to 3, 4 PM.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So soon the plumber bob will start to fill up with people.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, the nighttime activities will begin, that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I have to perform tonight.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't stay here, Eska.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry, I have something for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, actually, yeah, I'm not really sure if Eska would actually need to perform here, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, A, you could perform elsewhere and B, you're not on the clock.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you skip a night, it's only money that you lose out on, but nobody's going to have a problem with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's up to you when you perform.
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah yeah i think uh i think eska would perform but maybe not the plumber bob and he will also these guys himself as well so okay well do you guys have any plans for the evening as a group i guess like as a if yeah as a next step is
[SPEAKER_02]: Because, for example, if you want to go to the Head of Steam, it is the evening when the tavern is full of people.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it is a good time to go as opposed to when it's empty in the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it would be wise.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I can't make the decision because I'm Eska's performing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also it wouldn't be very wise for Eska to show up in
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can do both.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can perform and go.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've got the whole evening, if you want to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want you to be locked into the fact that you have to make money and can't go and do the things that you want to do as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: That definitely will allow you to do both.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because otherwise, yeah, it's just...
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's fun if you're just stuck.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, you're stuck in the... Definitely go to the Head of Steam, but maybe with other intentions.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's just go Death Ringing, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, where are we heading?
[SPEAKER_05]: The Head of Steam.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, let's go.
[SPEAKER_05]: And trying to figure out more about...
[SPEAKER_05]: what's going on, who's behind it and who's looking for the premium essence scores.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we can find a name.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should be grouped together or sort of split into two groups in the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's definitely better if we split up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, so if you guys are going to head there and enter separately, in what groups are you planning on entering separately, if that's the case?
[SPEAKER_05]: Where is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's on the edge of the furlong, in the core still.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll put you on the map for a sec.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I was just gonna say that I'm not gonna...
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't want to be associated with you, Eska, because if I'm gonna ever be in a situation like Madame Roop described now, I have to give information about you, I just don't want our faces to be linked together.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, I'll... Let's go to different groups.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, 100%, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're gonna go to a different group, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, where is it going to be?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I don't know if you guys can see that marker.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think I have to make it.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, it's not on your journals yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: It should have popped up about here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see nothing there?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't see a marker.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I do, I do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, it's hidden.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, there we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, okay, that means you guys don't see Billy's home either, some of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Billy's home is okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Billy's home, wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll fill in a bit of the information that you guys have.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the Guild of Engineers tower you know of, the Porter's Guild tower you know enough to know where it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is quite close to the Head of Steam, naturally.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, I think everything else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the college?
[SPEAKER_02]: The college is...
[SPEAKER_02]: on the other side of town.
[SPEAKER_02]: Literally.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's kind of a way away.
[SPEAKER_02]: But and Carrying Bones is on the south side here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the other scrap yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Field Scrappers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Field Scrappers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Fex Field Scrappers, I don't have a Marker 4, but I guess it would be...
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's in the core.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Claring Bones is like on the edge between the stacks and the core, whereas Fex Field Scrappers is probably around here, like mid-core area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Closer to the core rights and the Guild of Engineers side, like this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll make a thing for it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys see that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's I think all the all the main sort of things that you guys have found so far.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also Saladors is right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: which is also close to the brass line, which is here.
[SPEAKER_02]: But only really Lark knows about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, what groups are you guys wishing to approach this pub in?
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe it would make sense that Aska is a bit later.
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe he wants to perform first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oscar will go alone because then he'll do his performance and then he'll disguise up and then he'll go there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oscar, are you sure you want to move alone?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're the one that...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I am pretty confident in the disguise.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yes, that should be okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's still a lot of people in a lot of places where I can slip off to.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Asuka is going to perform.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other four of you go earlier on then.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I guess, yeah, I mean, you can arrive outside without needing to go in yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: A busy place on the side of the furlong here, a big workman's clock, steam-powered clock that dominates the street here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see the circular tram system that runs around the furlong.
[SPEAKER_02]: and is right next to it so this is a heavy thoroughfare the furlong here like filled with carts and stuff and it's basically right off it so this place is always very busy with a lot of people but particularly Porter's Guild people who have kind of adopted it as their like hangout basically and the main place that they go but it is large it is like wide and large and has two stories so definitely can fit a lot of people in there and so it's a very busy street scene as you guys approach
[SPEAKER_02]: you're able to kind of take it in from a distance before you kind of approach and enter as well, if you wish.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the four of you are here at the moment, so I see.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will wrap the scarf over my head a little bit to cover my hair and face, just to be sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think William is not
[SPEAKER_05]: Really trying to go in directly.
[SPEAKER_05]: You will more scout out the area, see if he recognizes any people or kind of stay at a distance a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just, you know, hide in the crowd, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Kaldor could go in in the normal, kind of normal clothes, long sleeve, gloves on, et cetera, nothing too special.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can stop by making a perception check, I think, Billy, from where you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's impressive.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is very impressive how bad you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah I mean there's so many people going past it's like really hard for you to kind of really recognize anyone moving in and out there's just crowds of people and you can sit there for ages and still miss half the people walking past because of the traffic so it's very tough.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess I would have to find a different spot to look out from.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it depends what your goal is, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the problem is there's multiple doors to this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's multiple, like, you can't just watch the entrance or something, like, there's so many people coming and going through multiple entrances that you wouldn't be able to, like, easily keep track of people going in and out.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I would look for the most shady entrance or exit, like a back alley entrance and kind of keep an eye on that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: If there's anything weird going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: makes more sense i think yeah sure i mean um there are definitely less used doors on off to the side but there isn't really there's probably a servant's entrance or a like serving bar entrance that you can an alleyway that you can keep an eye on but if you go any further kind of down that alleyway it starts to become suspicious that you're hanging out in the alleyway behind the bar right so you can keep an eye on the alleyway for now but you
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to head deeper in there, which you can, you can do that with like, you need to make like some stealth checks or some kind of checks to try and avoid the suspicion of you just hanging around in the sort of employee side.
[SPEAKER_02]: I won't do that just yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like Felix Calder, what are you guys doing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Mr. Felix, I have an idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe we can head in together.
[SPEAKER_03]: Calder is gonna go in as well, but let's go a bit separate.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a pretty good sight on people.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe if you can go to a table, I'll get you a drink from the bar and I'll just try to scout faces while I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: We go different tables?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think, yeah, let's just split up close to each other, but just split up just in case.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the three of you go in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bill, he stays outside watching sort of the back entrance, the employee entrance side of things as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Asker, you can do then a performance check if you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you just disguising yourself before you do the performance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you do that, you will roll with disadvantage on the performance check, which for you is a straight roll because you don't have the fame or the kind of existing audience, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's up to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you can roll your disguise kit check first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh wait, that's without disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so that's just straight roll with your dex.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope this is correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, dex 70 bonus, half your proficiency is correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you do a decent job of putting, what kind of disguise are you wearing?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think just like something that will completely covers the
[SPEAKER_01]: the like obvious features you know so uh i guess i would just i mean it's hard for me to disguise as like a uh the other species but like uh i like an ala yeah like an ala but uh i could i could definitely like uh put my hair differently i could definitely like make some are you doing any like full-on fake beard fake mustache type situation or are you like
[SPEAKER_02]: Because the thing is, you still have to be performing on stage.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't kind of do like a bandana over your face or something because that would be very suspicious.
[SPEAKER_01]: It will be with like, yeah, with like different, different beard style and maybe, I don't know, like extend my eyebrows or something like that, you know, that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fake nose, wax nose to change your nose.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: um yeah yeah yeah no that's right yeah i'm just wondering how different you you know kind of aim to look cool uh you can make a performance check then yes with this so this would be 22 wow well the rules 20 wait what 16 and 19 for 22 is crazy um but that should have been rolling straight because you have advantage on performance disadvantage
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I just don't know why that that didn't work for some reason but that's fine and it should just it should be Should just be a straight roll, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And it showed the disadvantage rule as a higher one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't know if that's supposed to happen No, the 22 is correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just the red arrow is just saying the whole thing was disadvantage Okay, and it's highlighting the 22 is the result, which it would have been anyway, so it's fine But with but yet 22 is very good Yeah, you
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to cut it slightly because you have a little bit less time to do it, but you make one ducat and one mark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: For your time playing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get out of there and then head on your way.
[SPEAKER_02]: But meanwhile, the three of you enter inside the Head of Steam, which you can see is a very busy interior.
[SPEAKER_02]: Has these like private gallery rooms on the top of the balcony level?
[SPEAKER_02]: which as you walk in you see like obviously it's full of people drinking, playing cards, dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a lot of like Porter's Guild paraphernalia on the wall so these like ropes and hooks and stuff that the Porter's Guild is kind of associated with is clearly like prominently displayed as a sort of like
[SPEAKER_02]: you know, like if you went to a military bar and it was full of like military paraphernalia, it's the same sort of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And lots of people in here are wearing like green, dark green coats that remind you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you know, as you walk in, you're like, oh, shit, it's fucking, it's those people.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then you realize that actually, no, just like everyone is not everyone, but a large proportion of people are wearing those things here as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there's this big sort of steam powered
[SPEAKER_02]: contraption behind the bar that appears to be controlling the pumps for pulling pints and stuff like that as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And behind the bar is a tall sort of balding barman who is wearing a monocle.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oddly enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: But beyond that, yeah, what do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: as you sort of three enters sort of separately generally into the area.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if I start, but I can start.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think I would go to the bar and just order a beer and then, then.
[SPEAKER_00]: hang on in the bar area a little bit, looking around, see if there's anything fun or interesting going.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't really also know what is my end goal over here yet, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you order a beer.
[SPEAKER_02]: A beer here is going to cost you a penny.
[SPEAKER_02]: which you can pay up and he slides over a kind of like a big wooden tankard overflowing with frothy beers and you can make a perception check here.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is my first not twenty.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you get a really good lay out of the bar and I think some of your previous dealings with certain kind of unsavoury members, as we now understand Calder does in his spare time,
[SPEAKER_02]: gives you a good understanding here of the mix of people in this area there is clearly let's say about 70 percent of them are just regular drinking people some of them porters guild some of them not just there to chill but roughly 30 percent of them quarter of them are clearly people that you would sort of associate with like criminal activity they just have the look of people who are
[SPEAKER_02]: not regular employed people, but more the kind of people that do things off the book, some of which are wearing green coats, regardless, you know, like you see people that you would go like, this guy looks like the kind of guy that would beat people up in an alley for money, but he's wearing his Porter's Guild coat, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So you immediately get some flagged alarm bells sort of ringing of like, some of these people definitely look like
[SPEAKER_02]: criminal sorts.
[SPEAKER_02]: With that Natural 20 you see that upstairs there are these private rooms which look quite fancy and you see that they're having drinks delivered to them by servers who like will take a whole tray full of beer and stuff and that and open them up and deliver.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's clearly important people in these rooms that have to be paid for.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see with the Natural 20, I will reward your
[SPEAKER_02]: The one good role of the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: there's about um there's about five doors up here four of which are regular like relatively normal looking you would describe them as like normal looking doors i mean still decently decorated whatever but the fifth door the one on the end of the corridor sort of balcony corridor has a like very ornate glass panel in it like frosted glass and uh just generally like has this extra level of like decor to the door that
[SPEAKER_02]: makes it just feel to you like it's even more designed to like show off, you know, like that particular room is even fancier is even more important.
[SPEAKER_02]: The person in that room is like the VIP kind of situation, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yet you see also a lot of people playing a game.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just going to make it a luck check.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think for you just roll a d20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucking hell.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's stealing all of them on that 20s.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So with another, yeah, you know this, you know this, um,
[SPEAKER_02]: You know this, this dice game they're playing very well is called Runs.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a like Porter's Guild dice game, but is now played across the city all the time, often used to gamble.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have played it with like
[SPEAKER_02]: it's a good way of like making friends in like the criminal circles and like you know getting as much like you know playing poker or dice or something like that kind of like a good way of getting an in into like a social group by just joining a table and playing some of this this dice game so you know it very well and you know how to play it doesn't necessarily mean you're good at it but you know how to play it right um and you know what it is that they're playing as you see most of the tables playing this kind of game um
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix and Lak, you guys sort of enter a little bit afterwards as Calder is beatily checking everything out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to a table that has a good look out on the doors upstairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll get you a drink and I'll just scout around while I do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, so it's two pennies, Lak, for two drinks.
[SPEAKER_05]: Unless you're not buying one for yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: What I do is I go through the crowd quite slowly and I try to see people having conversations, but especially if someone's really deep into a conversation and if the people look like a lot of hand gestures and facial expressions that they're like, yeah, deep into the conversation.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to try and basically eavesdrop on them.
[SPEAKER_02]: yes like listening yeah cool um yeah make a perception check then not too bad um yeah there are like it is quite noisy in here from the crowd of people around there is lots of people uh talking and boisterously uh arguing and whatever and you listen into a couple and some you know
[SPEAKER_02]: you focus in on a couple of loud conversations and realize that they're just kind of like bullshitting about random stuff that doesn't seem important to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But listening in on some of them, you do get like, I think from the 12, all you can get really is like, there are some more hushed conversations between people who are clearly trying to stop people from eavesdropping, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can tell that like, the ones you're listening in to manage to catch the words of are quite,
[SPEAKER_02]: boring or not boring but you know what I mean like not useful to you but the people that you're actually interested in are the guys like in the corners kind of you know leaned in and making sure that people can't overhear them yeah I'll move through the crowd a bit closer towards maybe a corner table that looks to be hushing their conversation a little bit I'm gonna carry the drink with me and just like
[SPEAKER_03]: Not certainly like go close like this, like what are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_03]: But just look at their faces.
[SPEAKER_03]: And try to use their faces a little bit like their expressions.
[SPEAKER_03]: What could they be talking about?
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe lips or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I don't think you can read lips, but you can make an insight check for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's so great.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't really tell any specifics without getting close enough to eavesdrop or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't read their lips.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just get the impression that they're discussing some kind of business that they're not interested in people overhearing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe using this large public space is a good place to meet for a more secretive sort of talk where they know that they can watch all the doors and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll just walk to Felix with the drink then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and could I have seen Larc walking over there in case I do, I would want to use message and then, you know, I think it's the first time I have used it now.
[SPEAKER_00]: So then I'm starting it with, hey, Larc, don't get scared.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then I would want to point out, you know, I have a feeling on those guys over there and I'm pointing the table where I recognize that they could be underground people.
[SPEAKER_00]: I feel like those are not regular so to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et cetera, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then also saying about this upstairs door and especially the extremely fancy door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did I see Vader going in?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there's like serving girls and serving guys, I guess, whatever they're called, serving people who are regularly taking drinks up there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, these guys seem like the big spenders as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's plenty of drinks flowing to all five doors.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Also, also the most fancy one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, all five doors.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I also relay this information to Larc that there's multiple information sources.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's the tables over there that I pointed.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you know the card game or the dice game, it's a very easy way to get in over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then the upstairs, the fancy room, there's a lot of waitress going on over there all the time.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think I can answer or know if I can answer, so I don't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you reply with message?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it says you can.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you, unless you tell her that you can, then she can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: She doesn't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the first time, so yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you also know the Dice game log, because it's a police game.
[SPEAKER_02]: So people at the brass line would have played it as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, you know how to play it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I go to Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: Um, Calder just told me that the- that table on the corner there, those people are, um, suspicious, maybe underground folk.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bad dealings, you know?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, the- you- you could get in there with, like, knowing how to play this card or dice game before you skill.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do- do you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I know it again?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think if anyone doesn't know it's probably Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't seem to be, it's probably not the kind of thing that Felix would have encountered before.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you don't?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if I have the courage to go there myself.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think someone should check on Billy as well, because he's outside alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: As Lark is thinking this, Billy, you see two serving, a serving guy and a serving girl come out of the back of the, they look like they're on like a smoke break in the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they're still kind of a decent distance from you, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can just see them down the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is it an alleyway that has like a dead end or is there a continuous path?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's like a T-junction that goes behind a bunch of other buildings, so you don't know whether it continues on or not.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I would want to try and kind of see if I can climb up somewhere and peek through any windows into the tavern, but I would have to climb and still try to be stealthy about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean you can wait until these, these people go back in.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so the alley is empty again.
[SPEAKER_02]: The only risk is obviously somebody coming out of the door and kind of catching you mid climb or whatever but risk I'll take.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the risk you have to take.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, so if you wait a little bit, like they will eventually finish their smoke break head back in and you can attempt to get over to the alleyway and start to climb up.
[SPEAKER_02]: It does look relatively easy to climb because there's a lot of gantry, you know, pipe work, all that sort of stuff up the sides of the walls of the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: The main risk is obviously people walking past on the street, looking down the alley might see you climbing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And also if anyone comes out into the alleyway, they might see you climbing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can make a stealth check if you want to make that attempt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: These have to be.
[SPEAKER_01]: You haven't rolled above a 10 this whole session.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You haven't rolled above like a five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, yeah, you definitely failed the stealth check, which basically means you noisily climb up the side of the building.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like there's not a way for you to do it quietly.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will let you roll the luck check to see if anybody comes out as you are making this attempt.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can roll a d20.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want 10 or above.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which we, as we know, is very difficult.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're the 15.
[SPEAKER_02]: Luckily for you, I mean, you timed it with the smoke break.
[SPEAKER_02]: The people went back in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Luckily there isn't anyone else walking out into the alleyway, but you have made some noise.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know whether potentially people on the inside might have heard you or whatever, but nobody reacts right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can make also an athletics or acrobatics check to do this climb as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So luckily it is easy enough for you to climb and you managed to get up to the second level.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you aiming for somewhere in particular?
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically like it's a two story building.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are windows on the second story.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy doesn't know what those represent because you haven't been inside the, yeah, but there are windows on the second story.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there's like a slanted roof that you could get onto easy enough as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Slanted roof on top of the building or across?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, on top of the building.
[SPEAKER_02]: The building has like a pitched roof that you can just get on the roof of it.
[SPEAKER_05]: The intention was to kind of peek into windows to see if there's anything going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think that...
[SPEAKER_02]: that you can do for sure because you've climbed up easy enough and you get to and these and you are able to immediately see into one of these rooms where you can see like in fact i'll even i'll show you you can see like this private room through the through the window on the other side where there is like a card table with a bunch of people playing and it's a little it's like smoky and people are drinking etc
[SPEAKER_02]: So you do see that kind of very quickly like little check inside what you're seeing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you want to do anything more than that, you will have to sort of make checks and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can initially get the idea of what is through this window.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll say that as you are as you are doing that, I think Asuka, you also arrive into either into the Head of Steam or at least outside the Head of Steam deciding what you want to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: um yeah i'll just head inside and i'll go up so you head in i think you see colder at the bar and you see felix and lark sat off to one side yeah i see called at the bar and i go up and join him and i ordered a drink do i recognize you instantly or yeah make a i think make a perception check
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you don't.
[SPEAKER_02]: His disguise kit was a 16, so you don't beat his disguise kit.
[SPEAKER_01]: A penny is a copper, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And how many copper is a silver?
[SPEAKER_00]: Four.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I have three coppers.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's four for four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I order a drink and then I...
[SPEAKER_01]: I wish we could call her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Call her!
[SPEAKER_01]: It's me, Eska.
[SPEAKER_00]: You first see like, you know, the open eyes like, what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is this person whispering my name?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm like, oh shit, is it my time to go out?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not your god.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just Eska.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the situation like?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what Billy is doing at the moment,
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I pinpoint Lark and Felix over on the table, and then I pinpoint a couple of tables that I identified for suspicious people.
[SPEAKER_00]: So in case you know the dice game, it's very good possible sources of information.
[SPEAKER_00]: But also, interestingly, there is some doors upstairs there, five I think it was, and especially the one, pre-decorated one, is busy with the waitress, so there is some, I would say, VIP persons probably, based on the decorations and servants, et cetera, going over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the
[SPEAKER_01]: there might be a lot of potential targets that we can question.
[SPEAKER_00]: Indeed, indeed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm not sure how we could get any info from the rooms, but I'm thinking if I should try and go play the card games with these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it seems like you're... Well, do you even know how to play cards?
[SPEAKER_02]: a little bit not the best these are dice games specifically not hard games but even though there's cards in the picture but i hope that i'm not losing enough too much money too so wait wait anything ask you for sure know this dice game as well because it's played in taverns everywhere so yeah yeah yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: But then I look skeptically at Calder and I'm like, how does a scholar like you know how to play a tavern game like this?
[SPEAKER_01]: I knew from my time that the scholars would obviously go out to pubs and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, how do you know that these people look more suspicious?
[SPEAKER_00]: First on the dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you know, my parents are engineers, so they play dices every now and then on cards, so we have played them together.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never played dice with my parents, but maybe it was because of my situation, but I don't think I've ever played dice with my parents before.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, go on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, it's
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice chill game, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course, not with the money, with the parents.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be like, oh man, I lost, they kicked me out.
[SPEAKER_02]: My parents couldn't pay rent one day because I won all our money in Dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's quite a problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, okay, well, anyways, Dice game aside, you seem to know exactly who is a criminal or who looks suspicious and who's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: How can you be for sure?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, to me, these all look like just any regular everyday tavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, except that, of course, most of them are from the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, but when you when you
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, I stayed here a couple of minutes just observing over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I'm starting to be decent at observing people.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's good to also good academic property to be observant for the fine details.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, those people who have a little bit more to hide, they tend to crouch a little bit more even though they don't notice that they do these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe fecling a little bit of the
[SPEAKER_01]: rings yeah okay well apparently apparently you're more than just a regular scholar but okay i mean if you if you think that the game is the best way to do it then i would say yeah try it i will uh do you have enough money to play at all to play in these kind of games uh what are typical amount of money that people would play in these
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it is going to probably vary between the type of establishment and place that you play it in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably people probably bet in pennies up to like a mark kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like you probably bet a couple of pennies and then maybe there's another round and you end up kind of like a bet like winning maybe two marks if you win the table, something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I kind of this sort of establishment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I have still enough savings to play a couple of rounds, unless they go absolute mayhem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I am not going to spend this wisely, and I gave him two silver, so it's just a mark, two marks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two marks, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just don't, just don't go spend it all in one place.
[SPEAKER_01]: All in red.
[SPEAKER_02]: Double your money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gave him two silvers and then I'll say, okay, I'll try to do my own investigation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I ask what do you plan to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I am planning to find out who our VIP guests are.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I also tell you that I have, as I spent so much time studying, that I know the message, so don't get scared if I whisper into your head.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know it sounds a little bit weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, it's from what I've seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is one of the least weird things that I've seen after what we've had dealing with.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, this might come in handy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, good luck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you say drinking at the bar for it for a bit as good as because my plan, my plan is to talk to the bartender and see if I can get information from him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just off the game.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So cold, do you want to walk over to one of the
[SPEAKER_02]: more suspicious looking groups of people playing dice okay cool you go and do that uh billy you are hanging off the side of the building uh there are five windows you know you're looking into the first window that you were able to climb up to uh what do you want to do from this point um i'm trying to look specifically at the people if i recognize any of them and if i don't i would try to move up to the next window see
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll say just for the purposes of kind of searching all the windows one by one, you can make both a stealth check and a perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jesus man, oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah I mean you you kind of have to like pay a lot of attention to climbing across the windowsills without revealing yourself as like this obvious silhouette in the window as you cross so it's hard to get good looks into the windows as you move along.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're also kind of smoky, people have their backs to you etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think even with a four of the first three windows you check you do not see the
[SPEAKER_02]: the two people that you would know, the blonde guy and the woman, you don't see them in the first three windows.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you get to the fourth window, the way in which they're like,
[SPEAKER_02]: gantry and stuff is like, you basically can't look into this window without revealing yourself you realize as you arrive there, like, you would have like the only way you can climb across this window to the next window is by basically like completely walking across the window sill essentially and being obvious in the window.
[SPEAKER_02]: If anyone was looking at the window, they would just see you having to basically like climb across it in a very suspicious way.
[SPEAKER_02]: So after the first three rooms, you kind of get stuck there.
[SPEAKER_02]: unable to look into the last room or the fourth window as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a quick question in between.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you talked about the two characters, this just came up to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have they actually seen Escar?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because obviously they've seen Billy, they've seen Felix, Lark, and maybe Calder, but I don't think they've ever seen Escar, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah so they don't know no no you were hiding in the alleyway you played music to stun them in the fight but they haven't actually seen you physically that's true i'm not sure if they saw did they see you calder they did right they saw me running at least over there but yeah i don't think they necessarily could have made a connection to calder being with us because calder was just yelling like these people are hurting an innocent person yeah
[SPEAKER_02]: So they might sort of recognize your face, but they don't necessarily connect you directly.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the blonde guy knows Billy specifically.
[SPEAKER_02]: who was talking to lark you came up to lark in the in the plum and bob as well so she would connect you and lark together and the blonde guy would obviously know you by sight felix cast whole person on the guy who so he hundred percent knows felix's face and obviously they know larks face as well okay um from that but but yeah nonetheless you guys haven't seen them in this in this yeah no no that just popped into my mind i was like yeah maybe i don't think they've ever seen eska so yeah yeah yeah good point good point yeah definitely
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool okay and so then as you decide what to do next here Billy as you're sort of still stuck halfway up the wall deciding what to do next Felix and Lark you two are still also sat down at a table on your own these are these like long tables like Oktoberfest style long tables where you're just kind of like sat on one edge and there's loads of people sat on the rows but in their own little groups so you're you're not on a table on your own but you're close enough that
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, there's other people on the table, but they're not necessarily listening in.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: You just got that message from Calder as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have any ideas, Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do I recognize SK walking in?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: yes nice you do i think probably not only like maybe not initially from the disguise but the fact that obviously he walks up and then leans into colder and starts talking to colder and stuff like that you you are definitely able to then be like ah yeah yeah yeah okay well as casual as you know lark
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's smart to discuss yourself like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: One idea I have is we could slip a note to the waitress that is bringing beverages to the VIP rooms that Calder mentioned to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's one way to get a person out from the room.
[SPEAKER_03]: If we would write something on the note that would sort of require them to leave the room.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, that's just a surface idea I have.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I don't know on other plans I have.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't have money to go gamble with those guys at the corner.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't even know the game, so I also can't gamble.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm sure they would teach you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just might have a bit of a disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: A real big disadvantage, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think, well, I think, like, you know that it is not massively a game of skill.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is more of a luck game than a skill game.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you could explain the rules to Felix if Felix wants to go play.
[SPEAKER_02]: Knowing our luck today.
[SPEAKER_02]: But knowing your luck today might be a...
[SPEAKER_03]: What if you go to Mr. Eska then, and I'll go outside to check on Billy, because he's alone there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_03]: And maybe think about this idea I had, because we could get a person out of the room, even a name if we try something.
[SPEAKER_04]: Check out Billy first, but he's up there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, and I'll head out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you head out, Felix goes over to Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you head out and around and you don't see Billy outside immediately, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an investigation check.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am investigating.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I'm not.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh my goodness.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billy is gone.
[SPEAKER_05]: Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would have said at least something right to the, like, I would be... You would, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would have said you were waiting outside to, like, keep watch kind of thing, but obviously you're not actually outside keeping watch, you're on the side of the building.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I am trying to find the crowd.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a perception check, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're looking around for Billy, but I mean, it's a big crowd and you don't see him anywhere where he might be.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, sorry, make a perception check, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a 10, but it's under 10.
[SPEAKER_02]: Down to a 9.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have minuses and everything, Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I just, when I have a plus 4, it steals a 5, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: um yeah looking around Billy you're kind of like a little bit stuck in being able to proceed further to look into these other windows um you well it's up to you what you do next basically yeah i have a plan okay yeah so i'm gonna use magic oh um i have a cantrip called thaumaturgy which has a lot of things it can do but
[SPEAKER_05]: My plan with it is to make a sound in the room that I'm trying to pass to...
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm sorry, I'm getting a phone call from my mom.
[SPEAKER_05]: Give me one second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's important.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm playing D&D.
[SPEAKER_01]: I really want to see the average rolls of today.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my God.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Impressed.
[SPEAKER_02]: My efforts are going up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm called a roll two natural 20s in a row.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, those were the first ones.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like, I think I already had the lowest effort.
[SPEAKER_04]: So yeah, mine only could go up.
[SPEAKER_00]: yeah so yeah you had you had the lowest by far then i it was me billy ice can lark is having the best roles before this okay so yeah what's your plan
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm going to make like, it's called phantom sound.
[SPEAKER_05]: You create an instantaneous sound that originates from a point of your choice within range.
[SPEAKER_05]: And range would be 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_05]: So my plan is to kind of make a sound at the other side of the room to hope that they kind of look back in that direction so I can pass the window and hopefully also look in while I pass.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sounds perfect, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, no role necessary to do the spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's definitely possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will give you advantage on your stealth check to dash across the room as you create.
[SPEAKER_02]: What kind of noise are you making on the other side?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can sort of see the doors.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think like a mumble of people talking close to the door.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, I don't think it could be like specific words necessarily.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, I'll give you advantage on your stealth check as you try and dash across with this distraction you've made for yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, OK. With a 17, yeah, everybody kind of looks suddenly as if because they think somebody's about to enter the room or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they look all towards the door and you're able to slip past and get towards the fourth window here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a perception check for this fourth window.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's actually it's actually statistically insane.
[SPEAKER_02]: Looking into this window, you see a couple of people you don't recognize leaving the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're not able to see their faces, but they are leaving the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest of you guys at this point who are inside see the door open to the fourth room, the fourth private room here, and two people come out.
[SPEAKER_02]: None of you guys recognize them.
[SPEAKER_02]: They look like porters guys, big guild coats on, but they just head towards the balcony and start to leave, leaving that room empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the fourth room there empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: as this is all going on ask it felix comes up to the bar next to you as well and you are also free to talk to the barman as you wish as well yeah uh i see felix coming up and i said to felix so did you find out anything nope not specifically okay uh well do i see a lark outside
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: You were with Lark.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where is she?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, just for asking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, if you see her outside?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's way too busy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, too many people coming and going.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you saw her leave, but you don't know where she is outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess anyways, I'll ask her like, okay, what's Lark doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where is she?
[SPEAKER_01]: And do you know where Billy is?
[SPEAKER_04]: Lark is outside looking for Billy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Billy was just looking to look outside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you by any chance good at dice?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I am going to try to talk to this barman and get as much information as I can about our VIP guest in the room upstairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I honestly don't know what you can do, but yeah, it's better if I'm alone while talking to the barman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe you could, yeah, try to see if you can eavesdrop on any conversation or something like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll just walk through the crowd listening in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a perception check, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You notice as you walk through the crowd that this place uses scratches to deliver things as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: The little rat-like constructs that run along.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's pretty commonplace to see them doing sort of deliveries of small things.
[SPEAKER_02]: It looks like messages are passed between like the kitchen and the serving staff and stuff like that via scratches.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you do notice that there are a few of those running around in here as well as you leave the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cold air.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's play some dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before that, before that, before I go to the table, I realized that if I want some information from them, I probably also need to give some information.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would want to send message to ask like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, based on what Lark said, you are probably the hot topic at the moment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there some info I can give out of you if needed?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like where you could have been, etc.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, and by the way, you can reply to these messages.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: I would prefer it if you don't give any information about my whereabouts, seeing as... Yeah, well, I am kind of a hot topic right now, and... Maybe... Maybe you could give some...
[SPEAKER_01]: false information about like the essence being found in another scrap yard somewhere I'm not sure but something like that I would really not prefer you to disclose any information of my whereabouts yeah and I send another one yeah maybe maybe
[SPEAKER_00]: We are not going back to the plant on Boomb, so maybe I can just say that you have been seen over there and nothing else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, if you keep it at really rumors and if you can't do anything else, then maybe that's the last case.
[SPEAKER_01]: But keep it as vague as possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you head over to one of these tables, you see there's a guy in a big Porter's coat, who is shaving head, he's got a couple of like scars on his face that look like he was in a knife fight of some kind, which is what obviously drew you to like that's not the kind of
[SPEAKER_02]: injury that a porter would normally get in the line of work so he clearly has some extracurricular activities outside of being a porter and then alongside him there is a guy in a regular sort of like waistcoat and shirt combination who has like a big droopy mustache he looks like older he's like longish kind of like graying hair who doesn't look like a porter to you but also doesn't look like the most savory character particularly
[SPEAKER_02]: And a third woman here who is also like Porter-looking, who is a Darkin, so younger than the other two, the other two are human, a younger sort of Darkin, she's probably like 20-something, looks like a Porter as well, and kind of looks at you as you walk up, there is a spare seat on their table.
[SPEAKER_02]: They all kind of like just turn to look at you as you approach.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm coming there with my drink and I'm like, oh yeah, you guys are playing this game.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard it's kind of fun.
[SPEAKER_00]: May I join?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's called Runs, by the way, the game.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says, she kind of sneers a little bit and says, you sure you want to play?
[SPEAKER_02]: We play for money here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good money.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can play a couple of rounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see how it goes.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I lose too hard, then I'm afraid I need to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, take a seat.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, you take a seat down there and they pull up the first round.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they all just throw a penny in for the first round.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can join in with a penny as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: The way the game works is you roll a d4, a d6, and a d8 in the first round.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your objective is to make a run, so that's like any concept, so like a 1, 2, 3, or 2, 3, 4, or 3, 4, 5, or whatever like that, subsequent numbers on those three dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the best possible run you can make, therefore, is a 4, 5, 6, because that would be a 4 on the d4, a 5 on the d6, and a 6 on the d8.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the best possible hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: runs so those runs beat basically then you just add up the number whoever has the highest number wins the round but if it if it's a run and if nobody has a run then it's just whoever rolls the highest numbers on the dice right so runs beat non-runs and that's how it works pretty straightforward however you after you uh a roll you get you have to reroll one dice
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have to choose one of the dice to reroll regardless of whether you have a really good hand or not.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's just part of the game.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you roll triple ones, you're instantly out and you lose your money.
[SPEAKER_00]: Triple ones.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you want to roll, please a, uh, so you can do like D4 plus D6 plus D8.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it works like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then it will roll it for you automatically like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see what you get.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she rolls that, the big guy rolls this, and the other gentleman rolls this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so currently the guy is winning with a 13.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody got a run, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, nobody got the run.
[SPEAKER_02]: And now you get to reroll one of your dice to try and improve your score, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think the best chance to get even tie, or the only chance to get even tie is if I roll the 1d4 to b4.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, remember, he has to reroll.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it goes in, it's going in order.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't have to choose yet, because it goes in the order of that they rolled.
[SPEAKER_02]: So because everyone has to reroll, so that these numbers will change slightly as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, just in order to get the highest possible number, she's going to roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she gets 13 still.
[SPEAKER_02]: The next guy is also going to do the same just to get a high number.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's going to reroll his d8.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he gets nothing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's basically out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the third one is going to reroll
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the D6 as well to make the highest possible number.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so it's a 15 to beat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my chances are now...
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isn't he 12 to beat?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, isn't he 12 now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because he rolled a 2.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, I was adding it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, 12.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a 12 to beat.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my best chances are either to get now higher or I roll d8 and hope to get two so then I have... Then you instantly win.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think the chances are better that I roll 1d4 from
[SPEAKER_01]: What happens if it's a tie Grimmson?
[SPEAKER_02]: On a tie you reroll again, like you have to reroll another dice again.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the best option.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I need three or four.
[SPEAKER_00]: With three it's tie, with four it's win.
[SPEAKER_02]: you tie and the whole the whole table's like ooh.
[SPEAKER_02]: So with a tie, this is the this is the like droopy mustache guy who kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now in this before you
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, I will say that you can use some like skills here to try and judge some information.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can do stuff like insight deception.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can cheat with sleight of hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do some various things like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not going to be pure luck.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do that now or maybe, or maybe on the next round, but just to let you know, you don't can use skills to do stuff if you want, like insight might give you a.
[SPEAKER_02]: An idea of like how risky he's going to be stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you need to reroll these last ones at the same time, like a 3-2-1, because obviously whoever goes first would set the score otherwise.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's got a 3-2 and a 7 right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: You did reroll again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no, from his previous... yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, I thought that we are rolling everything again.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: You keep the same dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're both drawing, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's on a three, two, seven.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're on a three, three, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have to judge.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're both going to go one, two, three, and re-roll one of those dice each, but you don't...
[SPEAKER_02]: you don't do it one after another because otherwise you would know what you needed to be.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you could use something like you could try and like insight to guess if he's going to go because he could go really risky roll like a d8 and try and get a one to make a run for example.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah or I can try a sleight of hand and get the d6 to be six so then I would have a three six six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I do that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can try a slight advantage-y.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh boy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, definitely, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's surely coming.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god!
[SPEAKER_02]: Goldor is just holding fucking nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Holy shit, man!
[SPEAKER_02]: So, however, despite how good your roll is and everything, so you decide to change your 6 to a 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so mine is 3, 6, 6 now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have a total of 15, which he is going to try.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can still roll a d8, and if he gets a 1, he gets a run, a 1, 2, and 3, and he will win, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But only on a 1 on a d8.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is what he's going to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you scoop up the pot and you make three pennies profit from that and they and the droopy mustache guy that you had the one on one with he kind of looks at you and he goes,
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, not too bad at this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You said you were a beginner.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, sometimes lucky, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I give a wink.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't really like lucky people at this table, I tell you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But look, you're on your way to a second round.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you say double, two-penny in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure, let's go double.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you put two pennies in, save the rest of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, to speed it up, it goes boom, boom, boom for this side.
[SPEAKER_02]: So pretty good roll from the.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that's not bad either.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's not bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not the strike.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So none of them are that, none of them are particularly versatile run either.
[SPEAKER_02]: So around.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the last guy is actually the last guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: The last guy can roll a two on his, on his default.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's going to try and do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, this time you will roll, you will go first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll reverse, reverse the order so you can reroll one of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: My best chance is to roll the one before.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'll roll that.
[SPEAKER_02]: so minus two plus five yeah okay you hit 15 decent um so going in reverse order the guy here i think if he rolls an eight nine ten eleven twelve yeah i mean his but his best chance is just to reroll reroll the d6 right
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah yeah yeah and try and get out yeah so he fails he's out that's fine droopy mustache guy like he kind of hits the table like yeah um the this guy will try and roll for a um oh sorry that's i'm rolling though i think he should have rolled his d4 to try and get it too which is what he's gonna do
[SPEAKER_02]: which sadly he doesn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he ends up with four.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, basically he can't win.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other guy here can re-roll his.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this guy's on 15 and you're currently on 15, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he is going to re-roll his.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yikes.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a tough choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on, come on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't cheat.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus, Aldo is so lucky at dice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see the, you see the, I mean, whether you act on this or not, you see the skinheaded guy with the knife scars tilts his dice and flips his, flips his three to a four, giving him 16.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just turn and look at him to the eyes and then I'm keeping my eyes on him and I say, so this is how we are going to play.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did anyone else see this one happen?
[SPEAKER_02]: with a natural one, they did definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: He kind of just like fumbles the dice, but I think he does it in that way of like, he knows he's fucked up, but he confidently kind of like squares his shoulders.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like who's going to fucking call me out, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You call it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are the one who's going to call them out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he goes, what are you trying to say?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying that, you know,
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems that this round of beer is on me and I'll take the money from the center.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can either make an intimidation check or a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Intimidation or persuasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Either you're trying to be funny and nice about it or you're trying to
[SPEAKER_02]: like yeah they're both minus one so he's gonna make it he's gonna make an insight check he has minus one on his insight uh he's not wise
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah he uh he kind of looks at you and just basically he cannot read you and so is like shit this guy's so confident that
[SPEAKER_02]: He must be secretly a badass.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm twice the size of this kid and he's just confidently calling me out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Something must be up here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he kind of goes...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, no drinks are on you next round.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll make the I don't know if people here would make the science for waitress.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: To get a round of drinks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you Yeah, so that is going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, ask it you are talking to the barman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I
[SPEAKER_01]: I rang up the barman and I said, so you're a good business here, I see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it always like this?
[SPEAKER_02]: So the barman is a balding
[SPEAKER_02]: tall, balding, quite large guy with one arm.
[SPEAKER_02]: He has the sleeves stitched up on his left arm and he wears a monocle on his right eye and he kind of looks down his nose at you in a way that you think like you've probably seen this before from some like nobles in your past of these people that think that they're very
[SPEAKER_02]: like uh above everyone else yeah but then he yeah above everyone else but then he has this big grin on his face as he approaches you and he says uh oh a new face i'm delighted to make your acquaintance i'm they call me the baron
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, The Baron.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a fitting name for someone like you.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Baron...
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, exactly, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, very good business, very good business.
[SPEAKER_02]: Happy to see all my Porter's Guild friends here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I used to be Porter's Guild, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's, you know, before I had the old accident and set up a place like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm glad to have you here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, well, thanks for having me here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's a really nice and busy place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, may I ask about the accident?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to intrude, but you know, I mean, it's something that seems like you used to be doing a lot of wonderful things.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now that I see that it's gone, may I ask about it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I wouldn't say wonderful, but sure, I was a porter, long time, you know, since almost the city began.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yes, one day, huge, we were hauling a crate up the side of one of the warehouses in the core, crate fell off, boom, straight on the arm, lopped it right off.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quick and easy, but obviously difficult to be a porter after that with the one arm.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I,
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, I retired, got a nice payout from the guild and set up this place here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that seems great.
[SPEAKER_01]: And well, it's a shame for you that you have to stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I mean, I'm guessing now that with business going so nicely, it's a nice change of pace, I'm guessing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's such a bit a lot of fun.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the people here, you know, these Porter Guild folk, you know, they
[SPEAKER_02]: They respect one of their own, and so I've been able to get some pretty good business from the local Portis Guilds.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, the Spire's just over that way, so they come after work, those that work there, and yeah, always busy.
[SPEAKER_01]: With this busyness, I've noticed that there seems to be something missing that I've seen in a lot of other places, and that's live music.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you ever considered that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you know, we had a couple of pretty bad musicians, honestly, that used to come around, and we just felt like it wasn't really adding to the vibe of the place.
[SPEAKER_02]: A lot of the guys here get a bit rowdy after a few drinks and things, and it becomes quite a noisy environment as it is, so we didn't really feel like music would help with that situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, yeah, I guess so, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you know, the thing is, I'm a wandering musician and I am kind of down on jobs lately.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, seeing as this is a new part of town, I thought, you know, maybe I'll try my luck here and your establishment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you know, I see a lot of people entering and I just thought it might be a nice place to try to get some gigs off.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you say?
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_02]: All you guys need to do was go to the pub.
[SPEAKER_02]: The pub solves everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: The pub solves everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: So with a natural 20, he goes, um, well,
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, if you want to make some real money, not this riff-raff here, he kind of jokingly points at the people here.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says, there's money to be made in doing some private shows for our VIP guests, some of the highest members of the Porter's Guild drink here, I'll have you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm sure they'd be more than happy to have a little entertainment for their games.
[SPEAKER_02]: They'll tip a lot better too, a lot richer than the run-of-the-mill folk we get in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that sounds amazing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't help but notice that the doors upstairs, I'm guessing they are for the VIPs, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would love to do a performance for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: As a matter of fact, I have my instrument with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you would be allowed to...
[SPEAKER_02]: to uh yeah i mean you seem like a stand-up chap incredibly persuasive um you uh but more than that uh how about a little baptism by fire you know i always like to uh test and you recruit so um the
[SPEAKER_02]: The room down the end there, that's our VIP room, currently got some, let's say, particularly special guests that you could perhaps entertain.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, I can send a runner up there and ask them if they want to go ahead with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And like I say, they'll kick you out more faster than not if you're not as good as you say.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you succeed, there'll be plenty in it for you, I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, of course, I would love to try it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, I'm really looking for a job right now and I'm down on luck.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anything like this would be great.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would help a lot with my confidence.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as I do that, I tap myself and I give myself bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think you can inspire yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you can't?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, no, that sucks.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that sucks.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think inspiration is only for others.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can guidance yourself if you have to balance, but don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn, that sucks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I was so happy with my story.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, yeah, I'm going to do this and this and this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You instill yourself with your own formalities, but not magically.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do I hear this going on at the bar?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think if you're still at the bar you were trying to overhear other conversations so you can definitely overhear this conversation.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just give Eske a tip on the shoulder good luck and I give him guidance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah I was like I actually I don't know this guy I'm just like yeah okay whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and you get a, um, you get guidance.
[SPEAKER_02]: What skill is it for?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you have to specify the skill this, this time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, um, you have to pick a, uh, ability check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah, I'll just, uh, use it for, uh, no, it's Felix that picks Felix that picks for you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to pick a skill.
[SPEAKER_04]: Performance.
[SPEAKER_02]: Performance, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you'll get a default on performance for the remaining.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's only a minute.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you do have to kind of get a move on.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he says, he says, yeah, he says, Suzy, Suzy, come over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And a darkened seven girl comes over to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's got a tray of drinks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he goes, what's your delivering that up to the VIP room?
[SPEAKER_02]: Take, take, I can catch your name, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, my name is, and I just make up a name, like, yes, I am, I don't know, Valor, the traveling musician, something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Valor?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not Valar, the devil in our religion.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Valor, your parents obviously didn't like you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, Valor, he says, Valor, okay, well, pleasure to meet you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pleasure to meet you too.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is your name, by the way?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they call me the Baron.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, the Baron.
[SPEAKER_02]: My actual name is, yeah, I mean, my name's Barry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not the Berry.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're running out of names, Quinton.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, like I said, people call me Baron.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's how I prefer it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and so you follow Susie who, who kind of goes, Oh yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, Valor was it come, come along, come along.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, harsh audience you've picked for the first gig.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hope they like you.
[SPEAKER_01]: What will be my first harsh audience?
[SPEAKER_02]: And you guys head up towards the balcony.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, meanwhile, Billy, you are still cleaning onto the side of the building.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, there's you've seen that the fourth room is empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, what are you wanting to do here?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I would continue to still check out the fifth window, see what's going on in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you start to move across there, give me another perception check log.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think if I don't see Billy amongst the crowd in front of the bar, I would go look maybe behind it or see an alleyway near it because I think he's maybe trying to be sneaky.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what I want to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Perception?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, perception.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll just see if you can actually spot him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah but your perception is bad but also Billy's stealth is bad so you were able to see as you kind of start to look in where he might be and look down the alleyway I think you just see him like climbing across the side of the building and just luckily not been spotted because nobody else is like looking up and around at people so you see him kind of climbing up there if you want to do anything about that or you can head back inside whatever but
[SPEAKER_03]: I just, like, notice him and then I turn around and I'm sort of start holding the alleyway so that if people are gonna walk towards the alley at this wall that I would be there to stop them because I'm just gonna look glance over my shoulder like what is he doing but I can't let people in here so now I'm gonna be a guard here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, yeah perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So making your way to the fifth thing, I think, as you do this, before we do that, I think, Calder, you get a round of drinks at your table and you can sort of, they take a break from the game to sort of chat and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you are free to sort of talk to these three people before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, before we do the other scene.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, God.
[SPEAKER_00]: You came to talk to them, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not just play dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you can just continue playing dice if you want, but... No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I looked at them, so they were definitely, like, at least one or two were the porter guys, and then there was somebody who was... Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's two porters, one a darkened woman.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's covered in piercings and she's younger.
[SPEAKER_02]: there's an older guy bald like shaven head big guy knife scars who's like 30 something human and then there's an older guy with this droopy mustache graying hair who is not dressed in Porter Guild gear
[SPEAKER_00]: I really wonder how I should do this, but I think I would want to go in the... Because I beat him in the intimidation and everything, so I think I would want to go towards the role of being a speaking person of some third-peak corporation style, so overly confident, this is bad for our business, etc.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would be asking,
[SPEAKER_00]: taking the drink and then looking at everyone.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what is actually going on?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, there have been so much hocus-pocus with this Porter Guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys are attacking kids on the open streets, beating up everyone, taking people out from their jobs.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, this is bad for business, especially for me and my boss.
[SPEAKER_00]: so you're not being overly confident and trying to yeah yeah sure sure sure um this is either good or i'm getting killed i don't know which one but yeah i mean i think um
[SPEAKER_02]: What was your previous intimidation check?
[SPEAKER_00]: 17, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: 17.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think they're still kind of like, they clearly think that you have some kind of, um, swagger here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I won't make you do another one just yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't kind of look at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, um, the, the droopy mustache guy speaks up the oldest of the three of them and goes, um, well, look, it's, uh,
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not really our business necessarily what everyone in the Porter's Guild is up to, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I can't exactly speak on account of us here on this table, but I've heard that there's a bit of, let's say, aggravation in
[SPEAKER_02]: Evan's crew, you know, Evan?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would I know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably not.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a politics check.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on, come on, come on, come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is a 16 enough?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think you may have heard
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to say you know that there might be an Evan up in the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know the head of the Porter's Guild is called Sasha, so it's not the head of the Porter's Guild obviously that they're talking about, but you've probably heard that there is like someone called Evan in the sort of like higher up.
[SPEAKER_02]: of the porters guild just one time and like a side conversation you don't know enough to know what position that person might hold or whatever could not it could be someone else it might not be the same evan but that's the only like evan name that comes up to you in relation to the porters guild when you think about that yeah i i roll with that but yeah i know okay and he goes yeah well uh yeah well i think this
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know exactly, like, Evan's crew's been, like, kinda...
[SPEAKER_02]: of pissed off about some dealings what went wrong or some some shit that's gone down and uh i don't know i got the impression they haven't been paid for something or they they missed out on something and they've been kind of hunting down the the culprits you know how it is you know you got to make sure people pay their debts can't leave any loose ends because uh people start thinking you're a bit soft you know you know can't uh can't leave them hanging so
[SPEAKER_00]: as far as I can tell they've been on a bit of a warpath trying to rectify these mistakes and like people get to hear about it right so they've got to hold their reputation up at the same time yeah yeah as long as it doesn't last too long we don't want to make any any rearrangements but events okay so I guess that will be the person that I'll
[SPEAKER_00]: Go next time too.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I assume this hypothetical case, we could buy some people back from those.
[SPEAKER_02]: You mean if they've got one of your people?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, kind of depends if they took them for a ransom or they took them for information or something like that, because you're not going to get them back if they need them for information, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, unless they give you the, unless you give them the information thereafter or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: If it's debts that, if they're just, yeah, I mean, they don't normally take people prison, that's a lot of work.
[SPEAKER_02]: They normally just,
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, beat you up, and they can make sure you pay, you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Taking someone prisoner, I mean, that sounds like a whole nother kettle of fish, you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Most people won't want to bother with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Problem is, you see, you're using the Porter's Guild prisons, starts to get a bit more involved, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: People in the guild start asking questions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who's this guy in the prison?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's he doing here?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, like, if you're trying to do stuff, keep it a little hush away from Sasha and them lot, you want to be,
[SPEAKER_02]: Trying to avoid that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, if they got your boy and you know, for sure he's in the spire, then that might be a bit trickier to negotiate with.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know it's business after all.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking, looking at those.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are not saying anything, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other two, you get more the impression that these are like the muscle of this little outfit, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Especially like the bald guy is just a big guy who fights, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So they don't really join in.
[SPEAKER_02]: The older guy does seem to be doing most of the talking and like the leading of the group, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I don't want to push my luck too much.
[SPEAKER_00]: I already got the name and everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I guess I would stand up and then I give the two silver, not silvers,
[SPEAKER_00]: What was the currency?
[SPEAKER_01]: Marks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Marks, pennies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Aska came to me and I just put them to the table that, yeah, this evening on me and we never had this conversation and then I leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice, nice, yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You used Aska's money to flaunt your work, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You think this is my money for bad things?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just for aura farming, yeah.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, you drop the you drop the marks on the table, so you stand up and walk off.
[SPEAKER_02]: So following Susie up the stairs here, Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, before we start, I guess, Felix, you tap Asuka on the shoulder, give him inspiration.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there anything else you or guidance?
[SPEAKER_02]: So anything else you want to do here as Asuka is like leaving the bar to go up to the VIP room?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you were going to go off and like do some eavesdropping and stuff, but then things changed with Asuka's plan.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you've also seen these scratches around here, if you want to do anything with that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to look for a secluded area where I'm alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, you could probably head into like the bathroom area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's pretty much guaranteed alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alone space, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll go in there and then I'll try to figure out a thing to work out with the
[SPEAKER_04]: how to get information from the scratchers or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess you could potentially like call a scratcher over to you somehow.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if you have any magic or anything like that to message or signal or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do have message.
[SPEAKER_02]: sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will say if you can make an arcana check, this would be arcanography.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you can be a 15, I will say that you can kind of just randomly point to hit a scratcher because the problem is you're trying to send a message but you can't see a scratcher currently.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's a hard check to start with.
[SPEAKER_02]: you do not beat a 15.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the problem with messages, yeah, you need to kind of like point at someone and these scratches are like moving around everywhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you need to kind of think of a way to either get them alone with you or do it more out in the open or yeah, up to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm trying to figure out different options and then I'll transform myself into a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I forgot that you could do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So no one can see you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got, you're in, you're in like the bathroom stall and then you transform into a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah so nobody sees this but i think there's like this kind of horrible um there's this horrible transformation kind of sequence where your body like um kind of sparks almost as if you're like a construct it's yourself but you're made of flesh
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's like a combination of like essence and sparks as your like body kind of like crunches into a smaller into like a smaller cube shape on the floor and you kind of like ride and it's I think this is the first time you've done this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think it's a situation of like you just thinking about how can I
[SPEAKER_02]: how can i do how can i do something with these scratches what can i do and your body like responds by just transforming you so it's an incredibly painful experience as you then find yourself on the bathroom floor as a scratcher and then i'll just go back and just find some scratches to talk to
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there are like little holes purposefully made in the sides of walls for the scratches to be able to travel through these sort of like rat like constructs they have like six legs they're almost like a centipede rat combination that kind of along the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: and you disappear kind of behind the bar and you find that there's like a little almost like a charging station the constructs don't really need to be charged but it's almost like a idle station that they just like sit in whilst they're waiting for something to happen they're not intelligent but they're trained so you kind of go along and you see that there's like three scratches in like a bank kind of sitting just doing nothing like idle basically
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll go there and then just ask a bit like, what messages have you sent?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, this one talks.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are not like us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: You...
[SPEAKER_02]: They seem very unsure about you, because they can sort of tell you're not a scratcher, but you look like a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is amazing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they kind of, it's hard to read them.
[SPEAKER_02]: expressions given that they are basically metal tubes with legs so they don't have much in the way of expressive features but you get the impression that they kind of like accept the fact that you're here they're not clever enough to kind of be think you're tricking or whatever and they say what what do you want
[SPEAKER_04]: that need some messages from upstairs from the VRP rooms.
[SPEAKER_02]: Messages, oh, one of them like pops its head open and inside it's like tubular body basically is like a cavity and like all the mechanics are like squished up to the side so that there's a cavity in the center of their body for carrying things.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it goes, messages in here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's just like showing you this big hole in the center of its body.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get the impression that the... No, there's no message in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get the impression that the Scratchers can't read the messages because they're just like carrying pieces of paper in this sense.
[SPEAKER_02]: So right now they don't know what messages were sent back and forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: They just kind of carry them or have the ability to carry them basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: You realize now as you see the Scratcher do this that you can actually detach the front half of your head and create a cavity in your body.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, this is a feature of a scratcher that you have now inhabited, but you didn't realize that it was even a thing and then you're like, wait a minute, I could do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I'll just go out and then just go myself up to the VIP rooms.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you go up like there's a little runner up the side of the stairs because they would never make it up the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's like a little chute, basically, that for scratches to go up the side of the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: You head that way, head upstairs as well and follow along kind of alongside.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, everyone just ignores these things because they're so commonplace.
[SPEAKER_02]: You kind of like moving along the side as Asuka is walking towards the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: And meanwhile, Billy is on the window about to look into the door into this room as all of this happens as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Asuka, you approach the frosted glass window of the door and Susie kind of knocks a couple of times and then just opens the door, walks in with the tray.
[SPEAKER_02]: She walks just straight in without saying anything, just puts it down on the side of the table and you walk into the doorway as you see four people playing a game of cards here.
[SPEAKER_02]: At the table, you see two familiar faces, a blonde
[SPEAKER_02]: Asma, a blonde Ayla that you recognize, a large woman in a green coat that you recognize, but you see two people that you do not recognize.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will show you their pictures as well first.
[SPEAKER_00]: I might have too many NPCs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we have the woman that, you know, and you know, here, and then you see a very well dressed, um, in a green suit, jewelry, glowing yellow eyes, slicked back hair, very
[SPEAKER_02]: instantly to you a noble look to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wearing the Porter's Guild green as well and sat at one of the chairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then the fourth person that you see is very, let's say shocking to you, I guess, because maybe not shocking, but surprising because this person is oddly dressed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where is he?
[SPEAKER_02]: He is cloaked in black and wearing a porcelain white mask.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ooh, Mr. K. Are you spoiling accidentally?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, but no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, true.
[SPEAKER_02]: He shouldn't have a name, but that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I don't know why he's set up differently than the others.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the heck?
[SPEAKER_02]: I know how to fix it.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's okay, you can just change names at this point so we don't know anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: True, true.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just fix this so that everybody's the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck, I have too many, too many NPCs in this game.
[SPEAKER_01]: This game's getting too big for the one DM.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, just uploading, uploading.
So small.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's better.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you see these four people sat around.
[SPEAKER_02]: You immediately take in all four of their features.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is any of these people...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, do you want to do anything initially as you open the door here before you talk?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like you could maybe like look at one of them in more detail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe... Well, it's up to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, I guess like I'm just waiting to be introduced.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm not going to say anything because... Yeah, but I mean, like you can make...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you've got enough time to do like a perception check or an insight check or something on one of these people before you get introduced.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it's like, who is your eye drawn to immediately?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like who are you most interested in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think my eye would be drawn first of all to the porcelain mask guy, because the other two I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: But since I can't really read much of him because he has a mask on and he has this really big cloak on, I would try to take in the noble guy because, well, yeah, noble, noble and that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's probably the one who's paying for a lot of this shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he does seem to command the air of, like, superiority in the room here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can make an... No, actually make a politics check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, politics.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seems vaguely familiar to you, but you can't place his name or...
[SPEAKER_02]: person.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you he's like someone you might have seen at a party one time or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that kind of like in those noble circles, you might have seen him once or twice, but you don't remember his name, particularly you just he's a little bit familiar to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you Yeah, you knock you knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: And
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, I think at the same time you hear the knock on the door in the room through the window and you were able to just peek around the corner and see this situation in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to do anything, you're at least in line of sight here for this particular situation, but you don't have to do anything further than that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And also Felix, as a scratcher, there is a small hole in the corner of the room which allows you to just go straight in and you are now also in the room
[SPEAKER_02]: as a scratcher, which nobody pays any attention to.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think Susie's going to introduce you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You watch her walk in through the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's just been told to take you to the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: She puts the drinks down, walks past you, and maybe taps you a little bit, like, good luck, kind of thing, as she walks past you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you're just stood in the open door with all these four people to look at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess I'll walk in, close the door behind me and introduce myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good evening.
[SPEAKER_01]: My name is Valor.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am a traveling bard and I've had a talk with the barman downstairs and he has set me up here to provide you with some musical entertainment for the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: May I, so I would like to ask, may I perform for you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, make a persuasion check first off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ooh, let's go, Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good, good, good.
[SPEAKER_02]: They all look towards you and the slick back hair noble guy speaks first and says, oh, that baron is,
[SPEAKER_02]: More than kind to us, how exciting.
[SPEAKER_02]: We haven't had music in here for a long time and I've always said to him, you know, why are we skimping on the luxuries of life?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, music is an art.
[SPEAKER_02]: Please, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is the corner, I assume you're a musician?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yes, that's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I take out my lute.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am a musician and yeah, I hope I can perform for you tonight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, yes, more than happy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see that the the big woman has has a bit of like ruddy cheeks from drinking and she's kind of like leaning back and the ailer is that same like dead eye expression of just like pure focus as he looks at you with incredible like, what's the word?
[SPEAKER_02]: intensity.
[SPEAKER_02]: As he just looks at you, his expression is remains the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see them the man in the porcelain mask is kind of looking in your direction, but seems a little bit uninterested in you in particular.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you kind of walk over to the corner, and you can begin to play you can make a performance check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice 23.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you begin to play what kind of music, what genre, what style type of music do you go for?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think seeing like I think Eska would take note of the situation downstairs how it's more of like a tougher puff you know for like tough kinds and stuff and he would play more I guess more intense is not the word but like more yeah like energetic more like not the usual strum that you get in like a no more tavern like the light wavy music but more of like the
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah higher intensity music uh let's just say yeah okay yeah cool death metal yes on the loop let's go off with a scream like yeah
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, everyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm Valor and welcome to the head of steam.
[SPEAKER_02]: You start to play and yeah, very, as always, very good music from Asuka as you begin to play the lute in the corner here and they kind of look towards you appreciatively, especially it seems like this noble who appreciates kind of the music the most.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other two here seem less
[SPEAKER_02]: interested necessarily as they play along.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess Billy and Felix, are you wanting to do anything here in particular or are you content to just kind of see how things play out for now?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll just see how things play out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah I'm also just trying to listen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Also, I would like to wrap up soon if possible.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: When do we start?
[SPEAKER_01]: 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have started at 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we've been playing for three and a half hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we are on the end of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you start to play your song and I guess the question for you Asker is really like what is your intention here?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, in theory, you could just sit here and play musical or night.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you have like a goal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the intention is to, well, to now that definitely that I see this novel that I recognize, the intention is to warm up to him and because he seems to like music as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'll just try to warm up to him so that I can maybe come back more often to play and maybe through things like that, I could get information out of it.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so I'm not gonna show everything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just gonna play one song and then just stop and then see what their reactions will be.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, after the first the first song is finished, yeah, the noble kind of like claps and then he kind of looks towards the other two and kind of looks at them and they like start clapping like the larger woman starts clapping and the A-largest light kind of claps with zero expression on his face as he kind of does like a little slow clap.
[SPEAKER_02]: The porcelain mask guy, I think, doesn't clap.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't even really see his hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: as this happens so um he turns to you and he says um this is the nobleman he says uh so i haven't seen you play before but you play wonderfully uh you are a frequent uh traveling musician around these parts or uh what i have heard of you or heard you anywhere before
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm just a musician who's at the moment down on his luck and like I told the Baron at the front, this is a new part of town for me and I came here to see if I could get lucky playing here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yeah, the Baron seems very interested but yeah, he said I had to come up here and show what I can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I hope you liked the performance.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm gonna need you to make it a deception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seems content with the answer and says, yes, wonderful, wonderful.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I love it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, you really must.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, you really must find a way to play here, improve the whole establishment.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I've been saying to Baron for years, you know, this place needs a little bit more lively music, something to keep the spirits up, you know, people always down in the dumps and sat in their drinks and that sort of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, I'm happy to see there's a man of the arts here in this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't play dice, do you?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, unfortunately my skills are in music and not in games.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunate.
[SPEAKER_02]: These lot here are useless.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can see he has like a massive pile of like dockets in front of him and like everybody else is like clearly kind of bombed out and has lost their money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, I'm very happy that there is someone who appreciates the music that I play.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yes, I hope I can play here more often.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's a pleasure.
[SPEAKER_02]: My name is Evan, Evan Langford.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, my name is Valor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you for having me and enjoy your night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anytime you're in the vicinity, please come and...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, regale us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very, very happy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if my compatriots here are not, you know, don't have the taste for music, I certainly do.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you go to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as you do, I think you know the name Langford.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sasha Langford is the head of the Portoscope.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Evan is presumably related to him in some way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you know it's his son.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's his son.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have recognized him before, or like you would, you put two and two together, like his age, plus you maybe seeing him at parties and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is, it's probably his son.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then as you go to leave, we will leave, you know, Felix and Billy still able to potentially do things here if they wish, but, uh, you go to leave the room and we will, uh, in the session there with this, uh, revelation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my God.
[SPEAKER_01]: We actually got information guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: We actually got, I think we've got info, more information than all of the other, all of the previous sessions put together.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: We haven't known each other.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, true.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is the guy you have to go talk to.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're doing a bad job.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not doing that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was so scared of the deception throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, oh shit, this is going to be the one throw that's going to ruin everything.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think it's really good that you bought the expensive disguise kit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that was the whole thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm like, you know, I can afford it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I'm like, I can afford it and I need it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm just going to use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I didn't ask guys in, I would be shitting myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a little poo that came out, but it was okay.
Yeah.